Welcome to another, as we've termed it, duo episode. That's just Jason and myself. No special guests this time. It's because we have a lot to say. We have it all pent up. So expect a high energy episode today. That's right. We'll start off by talking about email.
欢迎收听又一期我们称之为双人播客的节目。也就是只有杰森和我。这次没有特邀嘉宾。因为我们有很多话要说。我们憋了太久了。所以今天期待一期充满活力的节目。没错。我们先从电子邮件聊起。
What's more high energy? Spoiler alert. I do tell this to people in my meetings. I'm like, if you're in an afternoon meeting, I'm typically more ramped up and like you know kind of you think you'd be tired by the end of the day but i get i get kind of like riled up throughout the day yeah i wonder if maybe we're more common because i feel like isn't that more natural you wake up your brain still hasn't really like kicked in yet
还有什么比这更有活力呢？剧透一下。我确实在会议上跟人们这样说过。我说，如果你在开下午会，我通常会更兴奋，而且你知道，你可能会觉得到了一天结束时会很累，但我一整天都会变得越来越亢奋，是的，我在想也许我们更普遍，因为我觉得难道这不更自然吗？你醒来时，大脑其实还没真正清醒过来。
so maybe i don't know and then i just crashed at the end of the day but that's another another problem for another time. So as Jason foreshadowed, we're going to talk a bit about email. So this is actually a topic Jason and I were talking about. So we decided to talk about it on air, which is if you are not in a large organization,
所以我可能，我不知道，然后我在一天结束时崩溃了，但这又是另一个时候的另一个问题。正如杰森所预示的，我们要聊聊电子邮件。所以这其实是杰森和我一直在讨论的一个话题。因此我们决定在节目中聊聊，那就是如果你不在一个大型组织里，
maybe this is a foreign thing to you. But most folks, I would say, I've never looked at it actually. But I would assume a lot of people work in big companies. And in big companies, you get a lot of email, a lot of email, not junk mail, not spam, although I guess you could. But at my company, they're pretty good about filtering that out. But just like emails from random teams, random automated announcements, automated meeting notices, everything just gets pushed to email. And it's important to stay organized using either rules in your client or on the server, or just
也许这对外面的你来说是一件陌生的事情。但大多数人，我想说，我其实从来没有查证过。不过我猜很多人都在大公司工作。在大公司里，你会收到很多邮件，非常多的邮件，不是垃圾邮件，也不是垃圾广告，尽管我想你也可能会收到。但在我的公司，他们在过滤这些邮件方面做得很不错。只是像来自随机团队的邮件、随机的自动公告、自动会议通知，所有东西都被推送到邮箱里。使用客户端或服务器上的规则来保持条理很重要，或者只是
making sure you put stuff into various folders or flagging stuff. I think everyone has a different scheme. I got criticized actually by my kids because I have like over a thousand unread messages. Oh, see, I can't handle that. Oh, no. Oh, you're going to criticize me too. But I have a method. Like it is, I'm going to say like methodical. Like I do have a method to my madness. Like it is organized for me. I can't not treat incoming email. Actually, wait, wait, hang on. So wait, do you have a thousand unread because you, like you might somehow know the last
确保把东西放到各种文件夹里或者加上标记。我想每个人都有不同的方案。实际上我甚至被我的孩子批评过，因为我有上千条未读消息。哦，你看，我可受不了这个。哦，不。哦，你也要批评我了。但我有方法。就像，我要说它是很有条理的。因为我对自己的疯狂行径确实有一套方法。对我来说它是井井有条的。我不能不处理收到的邮件。等等，等一下，所以，等等，你有一千条未读是因为你，就像你可能某种程度上知道上一封
one you looked at, you know, the subject line. So you actually read them all. They're just all like handled. Okay, okay. Okay. So it's not that they're not looked at. It's just like sometimes, like you said, I kind of moved up, I'll move the meter for is this on me, this is bad habit, I would not recommend it. Like you said, I'll move the high watermark forward as like what I've kind of read through by looking at summaries. And most of me don't need to do anything, but I don't necessarily take the extra few milliseconds,
你看了的邮件，你知道主题行。所以你其实把它们都读了。它们只是都被处理了。好吧，好吧。好吧。所以并不是没看。只是有时候，就像你说的，我推进了标准，对于这是否需要我处理，这是一个坏习惯，我不建议这么做。就像你说的，我会把高水位线向前推进，当作是我通过看摘要大致浏览过的内容。而且大多数邮件我不需要做什么，但我未必会多花那几毫秒，
seconds, whatever, to kind of put those in an appropriate folder or get them out of my inbox. So then every so often I've just piled through and via searching, you know, call all the junk that needs to get marked as SRED. So it's just sort of like another folder for me. Like there's the unread and read folder and they sit in the same logical folder in my inbox. I would not recommend this approach. You should definitely be more organized than me. So I'll tell you what I do for unread is I have the, well, at least on desktop, I have like the double paned Gmail where like you
几秒钟或别的什么时间，把它们放到合适的文件夹里或者移出收件箱。所以每隔一段时间，我就会清理一堆，通过搜索，你知道，把所有需要标记为已读的垃圾都找出来。所以这对我来说就像是另一个文件夹。就像有未读和已读文件夹，它们在我的收件箱里位于同一个逻辑文件夹中。我不建议这种方法。你绝对应该比我更有条理。所以我告诉你我如何处理未读邮件，我使用的是，至少在桌面上，我用的是双栏的 Gmail，就像你
still see the list of emails while you can see, you know, an email you currently have clicked on. And then I have it set up to where whenever I like hit the up arrow, it marks it as red, you know, like as soon as it gets to an email marks as red. So I could just go up, up, up, up, up, up on the up arrow. And, you know, and I'll end up with everything red at the end. But I won't actually look at ones that are like marketing and stuff like that. I do. I am pretty good about taking the time to unsubscribe to as many things as possible.
仍然可以看到邮件列表，同时你可以看到，你知道，你当前点中的邮件。然后我将其设置为，每当我按下向上键时，它就会将其标记为已读，你知道的，一旦它移到一封邮件上就标记为已读。所以我只需要在向上键上一直按上、上、上、上、上。然后，你知道的，最后所有邮件都会变成已读的。但我不会真的去看那些营销之类的邮件。我确实会花时间尽可能取消订阅尽可能多的东西。
Does that work like in general? I guess at corporate mail, that should work pretty well, right? Like unsubscribing from something should make it stop emailing you. time is just like a one click on subscribe. But I think the most important thing you can do is to have folders. Folders are a total lifesaver. I'm not too sure what's the difference between the server side rules and the client side rules. That's one thing I wasn't ever totally sure about. So I think in some cases, so like you mentioned Gmail, I think it's a bit different because the most common ways of accessing Gmail are either web apps or progressive web apps, like they're on your phone, but they're still a web app. And so they're like the state of the kind we said, but if you're using like,
这通常管用吗？我猜在公司邮箱里，应该挺管用的吧？取消订阅某东西应该能让它停止给你发邮件吧？有时只需点击一次取消订阅。但我认为你能做的最重要的事情就是拥有文件夹。文件夹绝对是救星。我不太确定服务器端规则和客户端规则之间有什么区别。这是我从来没有完全弄明白的一点。所以我想在某些情况下，就像你提到的 Gmail，我觉得有点不同，因为访问 Gmail 最常见的方式要么是网页应用，要么是渐进式网页应用，就像它们在你的手机上，但它们仍然是网页应用。所以它们就像是我们说的状态，但如果你使用的是，
you know what, I guess that's pop or IMAP or whatever, you could have multiple different clients. And so if the clients are filtering, they're kind of notifying the server and moving and you could have two clients with two different sets of rules so if you access your emails from two different places and the clients weren't synced you could end up with sort of like not good so i think in gmail as an example when you write a rule it's just always a server side right like it always in the background when the mail comes in not when you fetch the mail, the server side stuff gets executed. Oh, that makes sense. So like you have a, you have a client side rule, but your desktops like not on. And so now like none of those rules are taking effect. So you're looking at email on your phone and it's unfiltered. Yep. Something like that. Yeah. I think most places have moved
你知道吗，我猜那是 POP 或 IMAP 之类的，你可以有多个不同的客户端。所以如果客户端在进行过滤，它们会通知服务器并移动，你可能会有两个客户端带有两套不同的规则，如果你从两个不同的地方访问邮件而客户端没有同步，你最终可能会遇到不太好的情况，所以我想在 Gmail 中，作为一个例子，当你编写一条规则时，它总是服务器端的，对吧？就像它总是在后台，当邮件进来时，而不是当你获取邮件时，服务器端的东西会被执行。哦，这就说得通了。所以就像你有一个客户端规则，但你的电脑没开机。所以现在这些规则都没有生效。所以你在手机上查看邮件，它是未过滤的。是的。类似这样的。是的。我想大多数地方都已经转向
to server side. Although I will say, I feel we at my company don't use Gmail. And in fact, I actually don't like gmail i preferred they killed it this is a rant another time inbox i i jive with the inbox way of doing it i was very organized when inbox was a thing it was nice they killed it and now it's gmail and now i'm unorganized again so i blame i blame bad tools and i know there are other ones out there people will send us links i know there are lots of other people and folks doing things that are clever. I just, yeah, I don't know. You know, I don't know if at some point I stopped getting ads.
服务器端了。不过我要说的是，我觉得我们在公司里不用 Gmail。事实上，我其实不喜欢 Gmail，我宁愿他们把它砍掉。这是另一个话题的吐槽，收件箱。我喜欢 Inbox 的处理方式。当 Inbox 存在时我非常有条理，它很好，他们把它砍掉了，现在成了 Gmail，然后我又变得没有条理了。所以我怪工具不好。我知道外面还有别的工具，人们会发给我们链接，我知道还有很多人在做一些聪明的事情。我只是，是的，我不知道。你知道，我不知道是不是在某个时候我不再收到广告了。
There was a period of time where I was getting, you know, Gmail ads. So like you go to look at your email and then the first email would actually be fake. It wouldn't be a real email. That was super, super annoying. They got rid of that maybe about a year ago or so. And so that made Gmail kind of like, there's not that many downsides to Gmail. I did like Inbox. What was so magical about Inbox? I also remember loving Inbox, being really sad sad when they shut down. But now it's been so long, I don't remember what was good about it. They've morphed Gmail over time to copy some of
有一段时间我一直在收，你知道的，Gmail 广告。所以就像你去查看邮件，然后第一封邮件其实是假的。它不是一封真正的邮件。那真的超级超级烦人。他们在大概一年前左右把那个取消了。所以这让 Gmail 变得有点像，Gmail 的缺点其实没那么多。我确实喜欢 Inbox。Inbox 有什么神奇的地方？我也记得我很喜欢 Inbox，在它们关闭时感到非常难过。但现在时间太久了，我不记得它好在哪里了。他们随着时间推移改版了 Gmail 来抄袭其中一些
the UI things. But it was just like the way of handling the UI and like what was shown in the ordering of like how you went through messages and stuff, which is different. I think the complexity on their side is around like needing to support both the old way and the new way. Well, one of the things I think they added was the swiping, right? So like an inbox, and then later in Gmail, you could swipe right to archive, swipe left to delete, or I don't know, maybe I have it backwards. But basically, you swipe and it goes away. You just know, it's just one of those things you could just do. All right.
界面上的东西。但它就是处理用户界面的方式，以及显示的内容和浏览消息顺序的方式有所不同，这是不一样的。我认为他们那边的复杂性在于需要同时支持旧方法和新方法。嗯，我想他们添加的功能之一就是滑动，对吧？所以在 Inbox 中，后来在 Gmail 中，你可以向右滑动归档，向左滑动删除，或者我不知道，也许我记反了。但基本上，你一划它就消失了。你就是知道，这只是你可以做的事情之一。好吧。
Well, we get on to our news of this show yeah my news of the show is simplifying lines with the douglas puker did i get that right puker puker algorithm anyways i know what this is but i don't know how it's said i have no idea how to pronounce that person's name i'm sure i butchered uh that person's last name anyways this is, but I don't know how it's said. I have no idea how to pronounce that person's name. I'm sure I butchered that person's last name. Anyways, this is really cool. And I found a particularly cool article where they kind of walk you graphically through how to do this. But I was always really interested in the game Worms. Do you ever play this game? Yes.
好了，我们来聊聊本期的节目新闻。是的，我本期的新闻是使用 Douglas-Peucker 算法简化线条。我念对了吗？Peucker 算法。不管怎样，我知道这是什么，但我不知道怎么念。我完全不知道那个人的名字怎么发音。我确信我把那个人的姓氏念得面目全非了。不管怎样，我知道这是什么，但我不知道怎么念。我完全不知道那个人的名字怎么发音。我确信我把那个人的姓氏念得面目全非了。不管怎样，这真的很酷。我发现了一篇特别酷的文章，里面用图形方式一步步教你如何做到这一点。但我一直对《百战天虫》（Worms）这款游戏非常感兴趣。你玩过这个游戏吗？玩过。
Yeah. So Worms was this, you know, pixel based physics thing where it, you know, there's also Scorched Earth that was kind of similar, but much more simplistic. Yeah, and Scorched Earth, like, things couldn't float, like the ground always settled. And so it was somewhat of an easier problem. But, you know, in Worms, there would be these floating islands and you could walk on them and you could bounce grenades off of them and stuff but anytime they there's any kind of explosion or anything you know it would chip away at these islands and it would start to take away some of the pixels and so i was always fascinated with this like like how do you bounce a grenade off of this pixel like you know this this 2d array of uh this binary array of pixels and so so that kind of led me to this algorithm,
是的。所以《百战天虫》是一个，你知道的，基于像素的物理游戏，它，你知道的，还有《焦土》（Scored Earth）与之类似，但要简单得多。是的，在《焦土》中，东西不能浮空，地面总是沉降的。所以这是一个稍微简单一点的问题。但是，你知道，在《百战天虫》中，会有这些浮空岛屿，你可以在上面行走，你可以让手雷在它们上面弹跳之类的，但是任何时候它们有任何形式的爆炸或其他什么，你知道的，它会削掉这些岛屿的一部分，并开始带走一些像素，所以我总是对这个着迷，比如，你怎么让手雷从这个像素上弹开，你知道，这个2D数组，这个二进制像素数组，所以这让我联想到了这个算法，
which is really cool. So basically, you could imagine kind of tracing the outline of one of these islands. And then just, you know, anytime there's an explosion or something, you know, retracing that part of it. and you know maybe an explosion caused an island to split into multiple islands and that's fine you could detect that but then you have this problem of okay now i've traced this island and i have this like you know the outline right the shell of this island how do i like put that into a physics engine right and and you know even like if you were to put every point in a physics engine, the angles would be all really jagged and stuff, right? And so looking at some game development
这真的很酷。所以基本上，你可以想象追踪这些岛屿之一的轮廓。然后，你知道，任何时候有爆炸或其他什么，你知道，重新追踪那一部分。然后你知道，也许一次爆炸导致一个岛屿分裂成多个岛屿，这没问题，你可以检测到这一点。但随后你就会遇到这样一个问题：好吧，现在我追踪了这个岛屿，我有了一个，你知道的，轮廓，对吧？这个岛屿的外壳，我怎么把它放进物理引擎里呢？并且，你知道，甚至如果你把每个点都放进物理引擎里，角度都会非常锯齿状之类的，对吧？所以查看一些游戏开发
sites kind of took me to this, which basically this algorithm is this really fast way of saying, okay, I have this, it could be a line, it could be a polygon, it could really be anything, but I have this, you know, line that's made up of a ton of points. And I want to keep sort of the structure, you know, the essence of that line, but get rid of, you know, a ton of the points. So it's a simple, unsupervised way to do that, which I thought was really cool. And the gist of it is you essentially like go from the start to the finish. I guess this wouldn't work if it's a loop. So there has to be other ways to do that. Oh, I think it actually it still works. We have to adapt a
网站让我了解到了这个，基本上这个算法是一种非常快速的方法，它说，好吧，我有这个，它可能是一条线，它可能是一个多边形，它真的可以是任何东西，但我有这个，你知道，由大量点组成的线。我想保留那种结构，你知道，那条线的精髓，但去掉大量的点。所以这是一种简单、无监督的方法，我觉得这真的很酷。其要点基本上就是你从起点走到终点。我猜如果它是一个循环，这就行不通了。所以必须有其他方法来做到这一点。哦，我想其实它仍然可行。我们必须稍微调整
little bit. But you go from the start to the finish and you you kind of draw a fat line, you know, like imagine like a rectangle that's oriented, right? Like a fat line from the start to the finish. And then you see like, okay, are all the points just in that line, in that rectangle, in that zone? If they are, you could just delete all of them. And now you have just a start point, a finish point, and a straight line. But if there are some points that fall outside of that zone, then that means, you know, if you were to delete that point, you'd kind of be changing like the
一下。但你从起点走到终点，然后你画一条胖线，你知道的，就像想象一个有方向的矩形，对吧？就像从起点到终点的胖线。然后你看看，好吧，是不是所有的点都在那条线里，那个矩形里，那个区域里？如果是的话，你可以把它们全删了。现在你只有一个起点、一个终点和一条直线。但如果有某些点落在这个区域之外，那就意味着，如果你删除了那个点，你其实就是在改变这个东西的
essence of this. So maybe it kind of like is more of like a parabola or something, right? So if you find a point that's outside of the zone, then you kind of do this subdivide type thing, or it's like a divide and conquer approach where you say, okay, let's go to that point and create a rectangle from the start to that point. And then a second rectangle from that point to the end. And now with these two rectangles, did I cover everything? And so you kind of keep going in this way. And yeah, it also looks like really mesmerizing. So it's a, if you ever wanted to make your own worms game this is how you would do it yeah i think there's a a few ways of doing this like line simplification this
精髓。所以也许它更像是一个抛物线之类的，对吧？所以如果你发现一个区域外的点，你就会做这种细分类型的事情，或者它是一种分治方法，你就会说，好吧，让我们去那个点，从起点到那个点创建一个矩形。然后再从那个点到终点创建第二个矩形。现在有了这两个矩形，我把所有东西都涵盖进去了吗？所以你就会这样一直进行下去。是的，它看起来也真的很迷人。所以这是一个，如果你曾经想制作自己的《百战天虫》游戏，这就是你会用的方法。是的，我想有几种方法可以做到这种线条简化，这个
one uses like you're kind of saying this fat line as like lateral stuff i think there's some that use uh sort of circular distance as well depending on what you want to do but yeah you're trying to like preserve the shape but also simplify the number of points yeah exactly cool my news article is how to pick a starter project now ironically or i guess this takes the stance initially of telling you how to pick a starter project for someone you want to get rid of um and by illustration of all the things that you do to get rid of someone, highlighting how to not pick a starter project. And it's kind of a funny thing, but I guess nothing in here is sort of earth shattering.
使用的方法类似于你说的这种胖线作为横向的东西，我想有些方法也会使用某种圆周距离，取决于你想做什么，但是的，你试图保留形状，同时也简化点的数量。是的，完全正确。酷，我的新闻文章是如何挑选入门项目。现在具有讽刺意味的是，或者我猜最初的立场是告诉你如何为一个你想摆脱的人挑选入门项目……通过你为了摆脱某人而做的所有事情的图解，强调如何不挑选入门项目。这有点滑稽，但我猜这里没有什么石破天惊的内容。
But reminder that starter projects really are important for onboarding new folks, like those first things that you have them do and making sure that it works well. It also gets in a bit to choosing mentors and that kind of kind of stuff. And I just wanted to highlight because I think this is a really poorly thought through thing, like how to onboard new people to teams. And some companies will have like a company wide onboarding process. But I think like still the importance of within a team, making sure new folks get up to speed and how that's like a joint thing across the manager, but also the members on the team.
但提醒大家，入门项目对于新员工的入职培训真的很重要，比如你让他们做的前几项工作，并确保它运转良好。它还涉及选择导师之类的内容。我只是想强调这一点，因为我认为这是一件考虑得非常不周的事情，比如如何让新人融入团队。有些公司会有一个全公司范围的入职流程。但我认为，在一个团队内部，确保新人快速上手，以及这如何成为经理和团队成员之间共同的事情，仍然非常重要。
And so here it's highlighting things like pick a gigantic project that has vague requirements and goes cross team and cross discipline and is tracked at a very high frequency by upper management. These are all ways to inspire someone to quit on the spot and to not get brought up to speed. I think like oftentimes, even under poor circumstances, people do integrate into the team eventually. But I think like often those formative first few months are critical to kind of having a really positive experience and making sure that the team knows that they should be
所以这里强调的事情包括：挑选一个需求模糊、跨团队、跨学科、且被高层管理人员以极高频率追踪的庞大项目。这些都是激励某人当场辞职并且无法快速上手的绝佳方法。我认为通常情况下，即使在糟糕的环境下，人们最终也会融入团队。但我认为那些具有塑造意义的前几个月对于拥有真正积极的体验至关重要，并确保团队知道他们应该抽出时间
taking time away from their other tasks to onboard a new person. And I think like, whenever you change jobs, it's always difficult in the beginning. And I can look at these comments and think back to some of the times I've switched teams or changed companies and had starter projects. It's more or less sort of, I guess, we're intending to push me away. And maybe I was too dumb to realize that I should have changed jobs. No, just kidding. Your starter project is to delete all the code that your boss wrote. I did have a starter project that was, you're new to the team. The team's been divisive about coding style. So why don't you come in and start enforcing coding guidelines?
放下其他任务来带新人。而且我认为，无论什么时候换工作，开始时总是困难的。我看着这些评论，想起了我过去换团队或换公司并经历入门项目的一些时光。多多少少，我猜，都是打算把我推开。也许我太蠢了，没意识到我本该换工作的。不，开玩笑的。你的入门项目是删除你老板写的所有代码。我确实经历过一个入门项目，内容是：你刚加入团队。团队对编码风格一直存在分歧。所以你为什么不来开始强制推行编码规范呢？
Oh, no. You've got to be kidding. Is that real? Nope. That's absolutely true. Anyways, it is important. And I think as well, if you say, well, well okay i'm not a manager or whatever i'm not assigning starter projects i i think it's important to to know that this is a thing and i think that people don't always do well and so if you're new to a team and you're not getting good work like be communicative to your boss that like you know or your co-workers like hey this seems like kind of vague like i'm happy to work on it but is there other stuff that i could you know, or your coworkers like, Hey, this seems like kind of vague, like, I'm happy to work on it. But is there other stuff that I could, you know, be doing as well, like be, be proactive,
哦，不。你在开玩笑吧。那是真的吗？不是。那是绝对真的。不管怎样，这很重要。而且我也觉得，如果你说，好吧，我不是经理什么的，我不负责分配入门项目，我觉得重要的是要知道有这么回事，而且我觉得大家不一定做得很好。所以如果你刚加入一个团队，没有得到好的工作，就要和你的老板沟通，或者和同事说，嘿，这看起来有点含糊，我很乐意去做，但是有没有其他我能，你知道的，或者和同事说，嘿，这看起来有点含糊，我很乐意去做，但是有没有其他我能，你知道的，也可以做的事情，比如，要积极主动，
and being an advocate for yourself and trying to, you know, assuming that they're not doing it on purpose, like trying to get work that you think is cleaner. I would say like, one of the more common unintentional mistakes is giving someone something you didn't realize that was a lot harder than it actually seemed. And so you give someone a project, you think it's really easy, and then they really, really struggle. This has happened to me before. And then it turns out, once you sort of start reviewing what you're doing, people are like, oh, I did not realize this was that complicated. I just thought you were kind of slow. And it's like, well, people really should be assigning work that almost they would just sit down and do in an
并且为自己争取，试着，你知道的，假设他们不是故意的，试着去获得你认为更干净的工作。我想说，最常见的无意错误之一就是给某人分配了一件你没有意识到比实际看起来要难得多的工作。所以你给某人一个项目，你觉得非常简单，然后他们就非常非常挣扎。我以前也遇到过这种情况。然后结果是，一旦你开始回顾你在做什么，人们就会说，哦，我没意识到这这么复杂。我只是以为你有点慢。这就好比，人们真的应该分配那种他们几乎可以坐下来在一个下午就能完成的工作。
afternoon. Like it really should be too easy, better for them to finish too fast than to get bogged down. Yeah. The other mistake I see a lot is, is where, um, if there's a junior engineer, um, you know, someone will, um, you know, a manager might say, oh, you know, I really wish I had time to, you know, work on project X, which is some new project that the team, no one on the team has time to do Project X. But if we did it, it's like this big win. And then somebody joins the company. They say, oh, this person has 100% free time. They just joined.
就像它真的应该太简单一样，对他们来说太快完成总比陷入困境要好。是的。我看到的另一个错误是，如果有一个初级工程师，你知道的，有人会，你知道的，一个经理可能会说，哦，你知道的，我真希望我有时间去，你知道的，做X项目，这是团队中的某个新项目，团队里没有人有时间做X项目。但如果我们做了，这就是一个巨大的胜利。然后有人加入了公司。他们说，哦这个人有100%的空闲时间。他们刚加入。
We're going to put them on Project X. And it ends up being this really risky thing. And for your perspective, you feel like as a manager, you might feel like, well, I'm giving them opportunity. Yeah, this person has a chance to hit a home run. And there's no downside because they just joined and they can pivot and they're not going to get evaluated right away or anything. This is actually a terrible idea, right? So the reality is people are under kind of the most pressure to perform in the beginning. And so this advice here in the article about put somebody on the main bread and butter
我们要让他们做X项目。结果这就成了一件风险极高的事情。从你的角度来看，作为一个经理，你可能会觉得，嗯，我在给他们机会。是的，这个人有机会打出一个本垒打。而且没有什么负面影响，因为他们刚刚加入，他们可以调整方向，而且不会马上被评估什么的。这其实是个糟糕的主意，对吧？所以现实是，人们在一开始承受的绩效压力往往是最大的。所以文章里的这个建议，关于让某人负责主要的常规项目，
project. I see people mess that up so many times. But yeah, as Patrick said, you want, especially for junior folks, but even for senior folks, you want them to be exposed to, you know, the core essence of the company, even if your long-term plan is for them to try and invent something new. Cool. So my article is tic-tac-toe in a single call to printf. These code golf things, I love these things. I've never tried it. I don't think I would enjoy actually building this. It's more of like an art installation than a coding exercise, but it is so freaking cool. So as you might imagine, there's a ton of pound defines to make this a reality.
我看到很多人把这个搞砸了很多次。但是，正如帕特里克所说，你希望，特别是对于初级员工，但甚至对于高级员工，你希望他们接触到，你知道的，公司的核心精髓，即使你的长期计划是让他们尝试发明一些新东西。酷。所以我的文章是在单次printf调用中实现井字棋。这些代码高尔夫（code golf）的东西，我太喜欢了。我从来没试过。我觉得我不会喜欢实际构建这个。与其说是一个编程练习，不如说是一个艺术装置，但它实在是太酷了。正如你所想象的那样，里面有大量的宏定义（pound defines）来让这一切成为现实。
There's a certain way in printf you can actually capture input. I did not know that. I didn't know it either. Yeah, it's, I'm trying to find it here now. I mean, there's a whole document here on how they actually did it. Anyways, there's a way you can capture input with printf
在printf中有一种方法可以实际捕获输入。我以前不知道这一点。我也不知道。是的，它是，我在这里找它。我的意思是，这里有一份完整的文档，关于他们是如何做到这一点的。无论如何，有一种方法可以通过printf捕获输入，
and they're hijacking that. And so basically this prints a tic-tac-toe board, lets you type in input and play games against yourself. The entire thing is done in one printf call. There is a while loop, while printf. I guess that's because every time you enter a key or something, right? But really freaking cool. And they actually took the time to make it like actually visually artistic so um the entire program is spaced in a way where there's a
他们正在劫持这个过程。所以基本上这会打印出一个井字棋棋盘，让你输入并自己和自己对弈。整个事情都在一个printf调用中完成。有一个while循环，while printf。我猜那是因为每次你输入一个键什么的，对吧？但真的太酷了。而且他们还花时间把它做得实际上具有视觉艺术性，所以整个程序的空格排布方式使得有一个
like ascii art percent n um in the program so it's uh um oh they're actually actually i take it back there is a scan f yeah i see that, I take it back. There is a scanf. Yeah, I see that. In the argument to printf, there's a scanf. Oh, okay. So actually. No, but that's still crazy. I didn't know you could, it does not seem like a good idea. Oh, the scanf is inside the printf.
类似ascii艺术的percent n在程序中，所以它是，哦，其实，等一下，我收回刚才的话，这里有一个scanf，是的，我看到了，我收回。这里有一个scanf。是的，我看到了。在printf的参数里，有一个scanf。哦，好吧。所以实际上。不，但这还是很疯狂。我不知道你可以，这看起来不是个好主意。哦，scanf在printf里面。
Yes. Oh my gosh, my mind was just blown. Oh, that's not that bad. It's just in the argument string. so like comma scanf open print so it's just a function call that's taking place and then the result going in as an argument okay okay okay this is not as like devious as cynical like as yeah okay this is so crazy but i got it now okay okay got it got yeah i got it too yeah so okay so it's a call to printf but that printf has as an argument i call it to scanf. So there's two functions, but the whole thing is freaking cool. I just I love seeing stuff like this. So definitely check it out. It will give you a chuckle and you can read through how it's implemented, which is very clever. It will give you a chuckle if you're either very against C or very deep in admiration
是的。哦天哪，我的脑洞大开了。哦，那没那么糟。它只是在参数字符串里。就像逗号scanf左括号，所以它只是一个正在发生的函数调用，然后结果作为参数传进去。好吧，好吧，好吧，这不像那样狡猾或愤世嫉俗，就像，是的，好吧，这太疯狂了，但我现在明白了，好吧，好吧，明白了，我也明白了，是的，所以，好吧，所以它是一个对printf的调用，但那个printf有一个参数是一个对scanf的调用。所以有两个函数，但整个事情酷毙了。我就是喜欢看这种东西。所以一定要去看看。它会让你会心一笑，你可以通读它是如何实现的，非常聪明。如果你非常反对C语言，或者对C编程语言极其崇拜，它都会让你会心一笑。
for your C programming language. I think that those two folks may like everyone else. Jason's description may be sufficient for you to realize you could save yourself the click. Well, you could copy paste this into your terminal and GCC it
我觉得这两类人可能会喜欢，但对其他人来说，杰森的描述可能足以让你意识到你可以省下点击的那一下。好吧，你可以把这个复制粘贴到你的终端里，用GCC编译它，
and then play tic-tac-toe. It'd be a fun exercise. They even have instructions on how to do that if you're new to the program. If there were only a web browser where you could just type a website and play web games that don't involve incredibly obfuscated C code. Okay,
然后玩井字棋。这将是一个有趣的练习。如果你是编程新手，他们甚至还有关于如何操作的说明。如果有一个网页浏览器，你只需输入一个网站就可以玩网络游戏，而不需要涉及极其晦涩的C代码，那该有多好。好吧，
this is pretty cool. I would say the name almost is also a good competitor for obfuscated. They did a good job naming it to seem to seem really sinister it also claims printf is turing complete which doesn't surprise me but sounds horrible yeah oh my gosh that's wild uh that's probably like a complexity measure of your language which is like how many features of your language are themselves turing complete? Oh, interesting. Yeah. I wonder, you know, I wonder what, so there's been historically been languages where I've had a hard time working with them. And I feel like that's pretty common. So one of them is Scala. Another one is Haskell.
这相当酷。我想这个名字对于晦涩难懂的代码来说也是一个很好的竞争者。他们把它命名得真好，听起来真的很险恶，它还声称printf是图灵完备的，这并不让我惊讶，但听起来太可怕了。是的，哦天哪，太疯狂了，这大概是你的语言的复杂性度量，就是你的语言有多少特性本身是图灵完备的？哦，有意思。是的。我在想，你知道，我在想，历史上有些语言我很难与之合作。我觉得这很常见。其中一个是Scala。另一个是Haskell。
Those are two languages where I don't have strong opinions i mean i actually enjoyed scala but uh but i found that the programs that you know when you started to scale up the team size scala and haskell both became really difficult for me at least to understand um and so yeah i wonder if there's somehow a connection like i wonder if you could somehow take all this anecdotal evidence and and regress it to say okay you know yeah somehow some complexity metric of the language causes it to balloon in this way interesting so why is python so bad as a programming language then what is what is the uh zeitgeist on python oh Oh, no, no, no, no. We're going to get demoted.
这两个语言我对它们没有强烈的看法，我的意思是其实我很喜欢Scala，但我发现，当你的团队规模扩大时，Scala和Haskell对我来说都变得非常难以理解。所以，是的，我在想这其中是否有什么联系，比如我能不能把所有这些轶事证据结合起来，做一个回归分析，得出这样一个结论：好吧，语言的某种复杂性度量导致它以这种方式膨胀？有趣，那么为什么Python作为一门编程语言这么糟糕呢？Python的时代精神是什么？哦，不，不，不，不。我们要被降职了。
We've got to keep making progress. Okay. I don't know. I don't know. We also have to throw JavaScript in here, too. Oh, my gosh. Okay. Mine is completely unrelated.
我们得继续前进。好吧。我不知道。我不知道。我们还得把JavaScript也扯进来。哦，天哪。好吧。我的话题完全不相关。
It's not an obfuscated C code, although it probably does have C code on it. And that is the Artemis 1 project. By the time you listen to this, hopefully it's successfully launched the time of recording, they've sort of attempted the first launch, which got scrubbed. But I want to say this had been a big deal for a long time for the United States government trying to send a rocket effectively back to the moon, this first one unmanned, eventually, you know, a manned moon base. Contrary to the last time that the United States and this one's actually being done much more internationally. Some of the sections of
它不是晦涩的C代码，尽管它上面可能确实有C代码。这就是阿耳忒弥斯1号（Artemis 1）项目。当你听到这个时，希望它已经成功发射了。在录制时，他们曾尝试首次发射，结果被取消了。但我想说的是，这长期以来一直是美国政府的一件大事，试图把火箭送回月球，第一次是无人的，最终，你知道的，建立一个载人月球基地。与上一次美国进行的登月不同，这次实际上是在更国际化的合作下进行的。火箭的一些部分
the rocket are actually done by the European Space Agency in collaboration with NASA. So I feel like this is a bit different in that way, leaving all the politics aside of the last one. But I want to say, I feel like this came a bit out of the blue. Like, it is a big deal, I think. And I think that it had been going on for so long, so much of a run, people kind of forgot about it. And then it was sort of like, oh, it's on the launchpad getting ready to go. And so that's pretty exciting. So yeah, I mean, again, politics aside, but I thought that back in like 2010 or something, they totally defunded NASA. So I was like really surprised to see this. So I really don't don't know how like what really transpired there. Yeah, I don't know about defunded NASA. But there's been a history of telling various government agencies in the United States like what to do, but then not giving the funding. but there's been a history of telling various government agencies in the united states like what to do but then not giving the funding so it's like a two-step process first you give them like a new mandate and then you're supposed to like go in in the budget sort of
实际上是由欧洲航天局与NASA合作完成的。所以我觉得在这一点上有点不同，抛开上一次任务的政治因素不谈。但我想说，我觉得这有点突如其来。就像，这是一件大事，我认为。而且我觉得它已经持续了很久，运行了太久，人们有点把它忘了。然后它就像是，哦，它已经在发射台上准备好发射了。所以这挺令人兴奋的。所以，是的，我的意思是，再次抛开政治不谈，但我原以为在2010年左右的时候，他们完全切断了对NASA的资助。所以我看到这个感到非常惊讶。所以我真的不知道那里到底发生了什么。是的，我不知道什么叫切断NASA资金。但美国历史上一直存在这样一种情况，即告诉各个政府机构该做什么，却不给资金支持。
like budget for that new mandate and so there can be like hey you need to go do x and then we go to make the budget we don't give you money to do x so are we really telling you to do x or not it's a bit ambiguous. And so I think that's true of NASA, but true of other government agencies, but I'm not sure on the particulars. But no, it hadn't been defunded. It had been sort of, in some ways, people will say uncancellable because it was involving so many states, so many companies, so much international cooperation. There's just all this stuff in it it just sometimes you know estimation for timelines we're not that software engineer is the only one who get them wrong um but other companies get it wrong too but no i i mean leaving that aside i think it's exciting like people quibble over the expense of it but i think that giving that that sort of optimism and
所以这就像是一个两步过程，首先你给他们一个新的任务指令，然后你本应该去预算中，为那个新任务指令做出预算。所以可能会出现这种情况，比如，嘿，你需要去做X，然后我们去制定预算时，我们不给你钱去做X。所以我们是真的在叫你做X还是没有？这有点含糊。所以我觉得NASA是这样，其他政府机构也是这样，但我不太清楚具体的细节。不过，不，它并没有被断绝资金。它在某种程度上可以说是不可取消的，因为它涉及了太多的州，太多的公司，太多的国际合作。里面有各种各样的事情，有时你知道，时间线的估算，不仅仅是软件工程师才会出错，其他公司也会出错。但我不，我的意思是，抛开这些不谈，我认为这很令人兴奋。人们对它的开销争论不休，但我认为，那种去太空并将人类送上月球的乐观和希望，以及随之而来的大量技术研究，我认为这是一件令人兴奋的事情。我不会证明它是否物有所值，我不知道，这很难说。是的，这很令人兴奋，比如我自己有上小学的孩子，他们的老师打开了这个，他们对科学相关的事情感到兴奋。我觉得从这方面来看，很难衡量这些事情到底有多大的影响。是的，我和某人谈过与此相关的事情。看看西斯廷教堂和金字塔，我们做这些事情，它们在某种程度上非常强大，但在同时又完全不重要，
hope of going to space and putting people onto the moon and the immense amount of technological research that falls out as part of this i i think it's an exciting thing i won't justify that it's worth the cost i don't know i kind of it's hard to say yeah it's exciting and like for you know having myself children who are elementary age you know their teacher turned it on they get excited about things about science. I think like from that stuff, it's really hard to measure just how big of an impact these kinds of things have. Yeah, I was talking to somebody about something related to this. look at like the sistine chapel and and like you know the pyramids like how you know we did these things that were kind of like really powerful and then also like like wholly unimportant at the same
就像金字塔一样。作为旅游景点，金字塔极其酷炫，我确信吉萨从这上面产生了大量的旅游收入。但当时，它可能只是一件要做的事情，或者是一项宗教事业。我其实并不了解金字塔的历史，但我觉得人类充满了这种类型的事业，虽然完全不清楚该做什么，但你会觉得这是人类的一个里程碑，不管它是否能带来经济效益，对吧？这总是很难的，对吧？我认为这些事情很复杂，但从庆祝人类在技术上所能做到的事情、不断突破极限、做这些新事情的角度来看，我认为这是不可思议的。此外，纵观播客的历史，一直有一个关于各种太空和火箭相关的主题，我的意思是，我想我甚至说过，对于我们今年的预测，虽然可能最终需要推迟或者别的什么，但是新火箭硬件涌现的数量，
time like like uh like the pyramids so the pyramids are extremely cool as a tourist attraction and and and i'm sure giza like generates a lot of tourist revenue from it. But like at the time, like it was just maybe like a thing to do or is like a religious endeavor. I don't actually know the history of the pyramids, but I feel like the humanity is full of these sort of endeavors where it's like not totally clear what to do, but you do feel like this is sort of like a milestone in humanity, whether it like turns it to something economical or not, right? It's always hard, right? I think these things are complicated, but from a celebration of what humanity can do for along this like technology, you know, pushing the envelope, doing these new things, I think it's incredible. Also, there's been a theme of various space and rocket related things throughout the history of the podcast but i mean i think i i said it i think even for our predictions for this year which probably end up needing to to slide out or whatever but the just the amount of new rocket
以及人们在做我们以前没有做过的事情。我们没有那么多双人节目，但有一系列其他有趣的新火箭正在走向成熟。真的很酷，很快我们进入轨道和接触月球等事物的能力将与以前完全不同。我真的很兴奋地看到我们对这种转型有什么意料之外的发现。你觉得太空弹弓怎么样？是旋射发射（SpinLaunch）吗？我想那是这个名字，对吧？
hardware coming online and people doing things we haven't had as many of these duo episodes, but there's a number of other sort of interesting rockets coming to fruition. It's really cool that soon our ability to access orbit and access things like the moon are going to be just so different than they were before. And I'm really excited to see what we're not anticipating about such a transformation. What do you think about the space slingshot? Is it spin launch? I think that's the name, right?
哦，是的。我不知道。你说的是那个在真空中离心旋转然后发射的装置吗？我的意思是，我觉得这是人们在研究中做过类似事情的一种，比如巨型大炮，基本上就是把火箭射出去。火箭方程是，哦，这可不是我的专业领域，但基本上就是你需要大量的火箭燃料来提升你的火箭，但你增加了火箭燃料，
Oh, yeah. I don't know. You're talking about the one that spins in the centrifuge that's in a vacuum and then launches. I mean, I think it's one of those people have done stuff similar before in research and giant, you know, artillery know artillery guns basically that would shoot rockets out the the rocket equation which is oh this is not my area of expertise but basically the fact that you need a huge amount of rocket fuel to lift your rocket but you add rocket fuel
而火箭燃料本身就很重，所以因此你需要更多的火箭燃料来提升火箭燃料以提升你的火箭，最后你就会得到这种层层叠加的东西，而且地球处在一个相当强的引力势井中，对吧？就是它的气氛很稠密，地球质量巨大，所以很难进入轨道。因此，如果你能获得地球直径的一小部分，或者地球半径向上，从而减轻重力的影响，减轻大气的影响，并通过你的发射装置（而不是你的火箭）中储存的能量非常迅速地穿过这些，你就会极大地简化很多事情。当然，这样做有其自身的加速等方面的注意事项。但我确实觉得，
and rocket fuel is heavy so therefore you need more rocket fuel to lift the rocket fuel to lift your rocket and you end up with this sort of like cascade of stuff and the earth is in a pretty heavy gravity well right like it's it's the atmosphere is dense the earth is massive so it's pretty hard to get to orbit and so if you can get uh just a you know little percentage of earth you know is diameter away or earth's radius up and sort of lessen the effects of gravity lessen the effects of gravity, lessen the effects of the atmosphere and just sort of get through those really quick by energy held in your launch device, not in your rocket, you simplify a ton of things. Of course, doing that has its own caveats with acceleration and stuff. But I actually,
旋射发射似乎知道他们在做什么。这不一定总是足够的，但他们以人们原以为不可能的规模建造了一些东西。我觉得有很多纸上谈兵的评论员，所以我希望它能成功，因为这个想法是，你有一个巨大的圆形装置立在它的一侧，它几乎达到完全真空，里面只剩下非常少量的空气，然后他们在中间旋转这个巨大的手臂，一端连着火箭，基本上就是这样。然后在合适的时机，他们释放火箭，它就像弹弓一样发射出去，冲向大气层，然后它就
spin launch seems to know what they're doing. That is not necessarily always enough, but they built something at a scale people didn't really think was possible. I feel there's a lot of launch seems to know what they're doing that is not necessarily always enough but they built a something at a scale people didn't really think was possible i feel there's a lot of armchair quarterbacking so i'm hopeful that it'll work because the idea is you have this giant circle that stands up on its side it gets gets almost all the way to a vacuum and just very very little air left in it and then they rotate this huge arm in the middle with a rocket on one end, basically. And then at the right time, they unleash the rocket and it's, you know, shoots out like a sling, you know, shoots up into the atmosphere and it gets
through all that hard, dense part of the air, gets to a pretty high altitude and then lights its rockets. And so it can be a much cheaper, smaller, more compact, and you can launch a lot of times because you just load a new one up and you do the same thing again. And so, I mean, if it works for small satellites, it would be a huge unlock. Yeah. I mean, it looks really freaking cool. I mean, Patrick did an amazing job describing it, but you have to watch the video it's just really really cool to to watch fingers crossed i hope it works and also good luck artemis and if you already know what happens in the future well yeah wait actually so we should predict do we predict artemis will launch in the next month okay well we're recording at the very very end of
穿过所有这些又硬又密的空气，到达一个相当高的高度，然后点燃火箭。因此，它可以便宜得多、更小、更紧凑，而且你可以进行多次发射，因为你只要装上一个新的，然后重复同样的事情。所以，我的意思是，如果它对小型卫星有效，那将是一个巨大的突破。是的。我的意思是，它看起来真的很酷。我的意思是，帕特里克在描述它时做得非常棒，但你必须去看视频，观看过程真的非常非常酷。双手交叉祈祷，希望它能成功，同时也祝阿耳忒弥斯好运。如果你已经知道未来会发生什么，好吧，是的。等等，其实，所以我们应该预测，我们预测阿耳忒弥斯会在下个月发射吗？好吧，我们在非常非常结束的时候录制
august you're saying by the end of september yeah so so i think this show will go out in october but anyways so let's say september will this uh will the will the rocket launch in september well the rocket will have had launched in september um yeah that's right nice job i'm gonna say yes just because i want it to be true all right yeah i uh i feel like it will too i mean they're so close right i mean i think it was just some kind of uh liquid leak or something i mean they could easily fix that flex seal just slap it on there and it's good to go now you know why jason and i are not rocket scientists all right yeah exactly oh my gosh
八月，你是说在九月底之前。是的，所以我想这个节目会在十月份播出，但不管怎样，我们就说九月份吧，这个火箭会在九月份发射吗？嗯，火箭在九月份就已经发射了。嗯，是的，没错。干得好。我只想说会，因为我希望它是真的。好吧，是的，我，我感觉它也会。我的意思是，它们太接近了，对吧？我的意思是，我认为这只是一种液体泄漏之类的东西。我的意思是，他们可以很容易地修复那个强力密封胶（Flex Seal），啪的一声把它粘在上面，现在就可以用了。你知道为什么杰森和我不是火箭科学家了吧。好吧，是的，正因如此。哦，天哪
the basic flex i bought flex seal tape the other day it actually is pretty awesome i used it to fix a hole in our our pool like you know the pool has uh your pool has that thing which like goes on the bottom of the pool um and like cleans the bottom you know okay yeah like a vacuum call it yeah basically a pool vacuum type well pool vacuum means something else that's like cleans the bottom you know okay yeah like a vacuum call it yeah basically a pool vacuum type well pool vacuum means something else that's like a thing that you manually do anyways so i use flex seal to uh fix a hole in that it actually worked pretty good i was impressed i think there was this uh there's this one i found online that i i also end up using for some other project that actually it gets hot when you stretch it and it like that the tape like
基础强力胶，我前几天买了一卷强力密封胶带，它实际上相当棒。我用它来修补我们游泳池里的一个洞，就像，你知道的，游泳池有一个东西在游泳池底部，然后清理底部，你知道的。哦，对，就像一个真空吸尘器，管它叫什么。基本上是一个游泳池真空吸尘器类型。好吧，游泳池真空吸尘器意味着别的东西，那是一个你手动操作的东西。不管怎样，我用强力密封胶来修复那里的一个洞，它实际效果相当不错。我很印象深刻。我想网上有这个，我也用在其他项目上，它在拉伸时实际上会变热，而且胶带像
chemically bonds to itself or whatever it's like wild i mean they have amazing crazy tapes now on amazon we can talk about the tape that's like electrically conductive sort of through the thin part but not across the tape so along the long part it's not conductive but like so you can if you you can pass through the tape but not along the tape electricity whoa that's wild okay anyways all right oh actually one more shameless plug so uh there's a gentleman that i know who started a company called bit rip and bit rip is uh basically i mean i'm probably gonna totally butcher this but imagine just like a roll of tape with qr codes and so the idea is if you're out in the field like you're an electrician you know like a you know a public utilities worker
在化学上与自身粘合什么的，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，他们在亚马逊上有神奇疯狂的胶带。我们可以讨论那种导电的胶带，通过薄的部分导电，而不是穿过胶带，所以沿着长的那部分是不导电的，但是，所以你可以穿过胶带，但不能沿着胶带传导电流。哇，太疯狂了。好吧，不管怎样，好吧。哦，其实还有一个不那么好意思的宣传。所以，我认识一位先生，他创办了一家名为Bit Rip的公司。Bit Rip基本上是——我可能完全会把这个搞砸——但想象一下，就像一卷带有二维码的胶带。所以这个想法是，如果你在外面干活，比如你是一个电工，你知道的，一个公用事业工人
or something you could just like slap this on anything and then you scan the qr code uh and put some data into some app and then someone behind you can like scan the same tape like a year later i see this so it's like every rip is like a unique code is it so is it like a non-repeating pattern like uh what do they call that oh man you know i don't know the details i always thought it was just like tape with qr codes on it but i haven't actually seen the product. Oh, okay. Let me see.
或者其他什么，你可以把这个随便贴在任何东西上，然后你扫描二维码，把一些数据输入某个应用程序，然后你身后的人就可以像一年后那样扫描同一条胶带。我明白了。所以这就像每一次撕下都是一个唯一的代码。它是像一个不重复的模式吗？呃，他们是怎么叫那个的？哦，天哪，你懂的，我不知道细节。我一直以为它只是带有二维码的胶带，但我实际上还没见过这个产品。哦，好吧。让我看看。
BitRip. Yeah, it looks a little bit like QR codes, but they're not exactly QR codes. Oh, yeah, you're right. It's almost like a barcode or something, but somehow there's a unique fingerprint. Now I'm curious with it. You brought this up, man.
BitRip。是的，它看起来有点像二维码，但它们不完全是二维码。哦，是的，你说得对。它几乎像是一个条形码之类的东西，但不知何故有一个独特的指纹。现在我对它很好奇，你提起这个的，伙计。
Now we got to know what the secret is. We need to get the BitRip guy on the show 600 gps tracking tags embed photos documents audio oh yeah it's definitely not a qr code it's it's some kind of like a penrose tiling if i just had to take a naive guess i think it's a penrose tiling which is like a non-repeating infinite series i think you're right yep yep but okay oh we probably messed up his pattern we probably should be here like reverse engineering tape on yeah so so how many of you think that in the month of september we'll get sued by the bit rip guy all right it's time for book of the show my book of the show is the meditations by Marcus Aurelius. So I remember first hearing about stoicism a long, long time ago and thinking to myself, oh, that's pretty much me.
现在我们得知道秘密是什么了。我们需要把BitRip的那家伙请到节目里。600个GPS追踪标签嵌入照片、文档、音频。哦，是的，它绝对不是二维码。它是一种彭罗斯拼贴（Penrose tiling），如果我必须做一个外行的猜测的话。我认为它是彭罗斯拼贴，这就像是一个不重复的无限级数。我想你是对的。是的，是的。但是，哦，我们可能搞砸了他的图案。我们可能应该在这里就像对胶带进行逆向工程一样。所以，你们有多少人认为在九月份我们会遭到BitRip那家伙的起诉？好吧，是时候迎来本期图书推荐了。我推荐的书是奥勒留的《沉思录》。所以我记得很久很久以前第一次听说斯多葛学派时，心里想，哦，那简直就是我。
I live like a really simple, relatively simple life, always trying to simplify things. And it kind of really resonated with me. And so years and years later, I decided to read this book. Marcus Aurelius is, I wouldn't say he's the founder of Stoicism, but he's the person who really kind of popularized it. And I guess, you know, it was a bit of a, what's the word? Like, I think I'd overhyped it too much in my mind. You know, it's kind of like, actually, Patrick, you brought this up before the the show how it's like another one of these books is the art of war by sun tzu where like everyone talks about these books all the time and you think oh this is like
我过着非常简单、相对简单的生活，总是试图把事情简单化。这在某种程度上真的很引起我的共鸣。所以多年以后，我决定读这本书。奥勒留，我不会说他是斯多葛学派的创始人，但他确实是将其实际普及的人。我想，你知道的，这有点像，怎么说呢？就像，我觉得我在心里把它炒作得太过了。你知道，这有点像，其实，帕特里克，你在节目开始前就提到了这一点，这就像另一本这样的书是孙子的《孙子兵法》，每个人总是谈论这些书，你会想，哦，这就像
gonna be something that's gonna totally blow my mind and what i actually found was that so many people have already talked about this book that like i already kind of knew uh what was gonna happen and so it really it's almost like kind of knew what was going to happen. And so it really, it's almost like kind of watching the movie of Jurassic Park after you've read the book, or maybe Harry Potter or whatever, any of these. So it's kind of like, you know, it was a little bit underwhelming because I'd already kind of known the material. But I felt like it was still a good book about halfway through it. If you don't know what stoicism is, or if it sounds interesting,
会是一件彻底震撼我脑海的事情。而我实际发现的是，已经有这么多人讨论过这本书了，所以其实我差不多已经知道会发生什么了，所以它真的，几乎就像是差不多知道会发生什么。所以它真的，几乎就像是在读完书之后看《侏罗纪公园》的电影，或者可能是《哈利·波特》什么的，任何这些。所以这有点像，你知道的，有点让人扫兴，因为我已经大致了解了这些内容。但我仍然觉得这是一本不错的好书，读到一半左右的时候。如果你不知道什么是斯多葛学派，或者如果这听起来很有趣，
if you're interested in how to lead a simple life, like what that means for like metaphysically and everything, check it out. It's a good book. It's also, you know, obviously really dated. I think Marcus Aurelius was what, like a Greek emperor, I think, or Roman emperor. I think Roman emperor. Yeah, Caesar, right. A Roman emperor. Roman emperor. There you go. So, yeah. So, I think it's going to be a very dated book, but it's a little difficult to read. But I think it's nice. And it could be sort of something that you do while you're in the car and just kind of have it in the background. And there's probably a lot more contemporary books on St stoicism and the other kind of philosophies I highly recommend.
如果你对如何过上简单生活感兴趣，这在形而上学等方面意味着什么，去看看吧。这是一本好书。它也，你知道的，显然真的很过时。我想奥勒留是什么，像一个希腊皇帝，我想，或者罗马皇帝？我认为是罗马皇帝。对，凯撒，对吧？罗马皇帝。罗马皇帝。给你。所以，是的。所以，我认为这是一本非常过时的书，但读起来有点难。不过我认为它挺不错的。它可能有点像你在车里时做的事情，就让它在背景里播放。而且可能还有很多关于斯多葛学派和其他哲学的更现代的书籍，我强烈推荐。
I think understanding some of those philosophies and approaches, even if you're not saying, hey, I'm actively seeking to model my life or to do this as like a key tenant, I think still are useful for helping see how other people think to just like have new ideas and to kind of like question if there's some nugget of value there for some part of your life rather than necessarily reading a self-help book where you're saying, I'm going to adopt this as like everything about who I am and make it my core identity. I feel sometimes there's, I don't want to say like a pressure, but in my head, at least like a thought, like, well, if I read this, I'm kind of wanting to adopt it as like, and I don't think that's accurate. I think like Jason's pointing out, you can read it and still learn a lot from it.
我认为理解其中一些哲学和方法，即使你没有说，嘿，我正积极寻求将我的生活模式化，或者将其作为核心原则，我认为对于帮助了解其他人如何思考、产生新想法以及质疑你的生活的某个部分是否存在某些价值金块仍然很有用，而不是非得读一本自我提升的书，然后说，我要把它当作我的一切并将其作为我的核心身份。有时我觉得有，我不想说是压力，但在我脑子里，至少有一个想法，那就是，如果我读了这个，我有点想把它当作，而且我觉得这不准确。我认为就像杰森指出的那样，你可以阅读它，仍然可以从中学到很多东西。
Yeah, I think, you know, I was really fascinated when, you know, we were working on YouTube. I was really fascinated at like, what made things go viral? You know, like what actually makes things go viral and one thing that uh i learned in that process is that a lot of things that you think are organic are actually not organic right so there's there's actually a lot of uh viral videos where you look at that and say oh man you know perfect timing but it's actually highly, highly scripted. So it's very hard to tell what's real, what's fake. But either way, I think that what I noticed was a lot of viral content on really anything, any type of media, it sort of taps into this kind of like latent, I don't know how you describe it, just like latent, like shared common sort of culture, like the sort of like hive mind of humanity or maybe hive mind of, if you want to be more local, like hive mind to your country or your region or whatever.
是的，我觉得，你知道的，当我们在做YouTube时，我真的很着迷。我真的很着迷于是什么让事情病毒式传播？你知道的，像是什么真正让事情病毒式传播。我在那个过程中学到的一件事是，许多你认为是有机传播的事情其实并不是有机传播的，对吧？所以实际上有很多病毒式视频，你看着它们会说，哦，天哪，你知道的，完美的时机，但它实际上是高度、高度剧本化的。所以很难分辨什么是真的，什么是假的。但无论哪种方式，我注意到的是，关于任何事情、任何类型媒体的很多病毒式内容，它在某种程度上利用了这种潜在的，我不知道你怎么形容它，就像潜在的、共享的共同文化，就像人类的集体潜意识，或者如果你想更局部一点，就像你的国家、你的地区或无论什么的集体潜意识。
It's like it doesn't directly say like, hey, you know, we're going to talk about stoicism today. But it just like it sort of taps into a lot of that sort of latent energy like harry potter is the example that keeps coming up in my mind how if you actually look almost all of those stories like like the at one point they fight a snake and that snake like harry potter fighting the snake is like you can you can see the parallel to this other like ancient story that that people read for like hundreds and hundreds of years and so it's like you can you can see the parallel to this other like ancient story that that people read for like hundreds and hundreds of years and so it's like you have this evolutionary like footprint you know and really popular content sort of like taps into like piggybacks on that on that footprint
它就像没有直接说，嘿，你知道的，我们今天要谈论斯多葛学派。但它只是，它在某种程度上利用了那种潜在的能量。就像《哈利·波特》这个一直浮现在我脑海中的例子，如果你真的去看看几乎所有这些故事，比如在某个时刻他们与一条蛇战斗，那条蛇就像哈利·波特与蛇战斗一样，你可以，你可以看到这与人们阅读了数百年的其他古老故事的相似之处，所以就像你可以，你可以看到这与人们阅读了数百年的其他古老故事的相似之处，所以就像你拥有这种进化的足迹，你知道的，非常受欢迎的内容有点像利用、搭便车在那条足迹上
um and so yeah reading like a lot of these canonical books will give you kind of like an understanding into into that which would help you if you ever wanted to write uh you know produce some content uh like like write a book or or or anything like that that that uh wants to tap into that that same energy well as tradition holds jason gave us a very highbrow uh very thoughtful book. This may be a bit late, but we've not done as many of these recently. So it was all the fad during sort of like the COVID at home stuff to kind of bake sourdough. I see that. I see that meme. I remember that. Mine is a book about bread baking, Flour, Water, Salt, Yeast by a gentleman named Ken Forkish. And there are a lot of books about bread making and artisan bread. And I think this one, for whatever reason, just reading it in the stories,
所以，是的，阅读很多这些经典的著作会让你对那方面有所理解，如果你曾经想写，你知道的，制作一些内容，比如写一本书或任何类似的事情，想要利用那种相同的能量，这将对你有所帮助。好吧，按照惯例，杰森给我们带来了一本非常阳春白雪、非常深思熟虑的书。这可能有点晚了，但我们最近没有做太多这样的事情。所以在COVID居家期间，烤酸面包是一种风靡一时的潮流。我看到了。我看到了那个梗。我记得那个。我的是一本关于面包烘焙的书，由一位名叫肯·福基什（Ken Forkish）的先生所写的《面粉、水、盐、酵母》。有很多关于面包制作和手作面包的书，我想这一本，不管什么原因，只是阅读它和里面的故事，
it really kind of like made me excited to try the recipes, to do them, to take the approach. I just thought it was a very thoughtful way of thinking about bread baking. That's a tough one. There we go i can uh and um you know just using simple ingredients i guess they call it sort of like a lean bread which is there's no there's no fat in it right just flour water salt and yeast um they of course have is that literal like do they literally put fat in bread yeah so an enriched bread so like if you i mean like a challah bread or uh you know something like an egg roll right or like a yeast you put egg or butter or oil like a lot of pizza doughs
它真的有点让我兴奋地去尝试食谱，去做它们，采取这种方法。我只是觉得这是一种对面包烘焙非常深思熟虑的思考方式。这是一个难题。好了，我能，呃，你知道的，只是使用简单的成分，我想他们称之为一种精瘦面包（lean bread），里面没有任何脂肪，只有面粉、水、盐和酵母。它们当然有，这是字面意思吗？他们真的在面包里放脂肪吗？是的，所以是丰富面包（enriched bread），比如如果你，我的意思是，就像哈拉面包（challah）或，你知道的，像某种蛋卷，或者像酵母，你放鸡蛋、黄油或油，很多披萨面团
have oil in them wow okay that makes sense yeah pizza dough yeah and so and so they those would be like enriched in some way with some kind of fat and so they're like and a lot of bread we eat has a little bit of that and so kind of going back to this very basic sort of loose shaped you know round bread gained popularity i know in like on the west coast of america the the sort of like portland and san francisco these places have like kind of developed a a renaissance of this style bread making. But if you're interested in bread making, which most of you probably aren't, that's fine. I would encourage you to check out this book. I really like this book. I baked a lot of the
里面有油。哇，好吧，这说得通。是的，披萨面团，对。所以，它们会以某种脂肪在某种程度上变得丰富。所以它们像，我们吃很多面包都有点那个。所以回到这种非常基本的、松散形状的圆面包，我知道在像美国西海岸，波特兰和旧金山这些地方，这种风格的面包制作经历了一场复兴。但如果你对面包制作感兴趣，你们大多数人可能不感兴趣，没关系。我鼓励你看看这本书。我很喜欢这本书。我烤了很多
recipes in here and had a good time. You know, I don't get super, super into it. Probably should do it more. But it does take quite a while. It's an endeavor, but it feels good at the end to really eat it. And there is something hugely different about eating a loaf of bread, you know, smelling it, cooling it, eating it that you made versus, you know, going to the store and buying one. And so I think it's something that people should try at least once. Yeah, this is super cool. So I was looking up the author to see if Ken Forkish is the real name or not. It just seems like too good to be true to write a book about cooking and he has fork in it. But so far, everything I look up say it's not a pseudonym. There's actually a real guy named Ken Forkish.
这里的食谱，度过了一段美好的时光。你知道的，我没有沉迷得超级超级深。可能应该多做一点。但这确实需要很长时间。这是一项大工程，但最后真正吃掉它的感觉很好。吃一条你亲手制作的面包，闻到它的香味，冷却，吃掉它，与去商店买一个相比，有着巨大的不同。所以我想这是人们至少应该尝试一次的事情。是的，这超级酷。所以我一直在查作者，看看Ken Forkish是不是真名。写一本关于烹饪的书，名字里刚好有fork（叉子），这感觉好得有点不真实。但到目前为止，我查到的一切都说这不是化名。确实有一个叫Ken Forkish的真实人物。
I didn't even think about that until you said it. Yeah, I think he runs a restaurant in, I think, Portland. That's right. Yeah, you got it. He runs a bakery in Portland. And he actually, before opening that bakery in 2001, he worked in Silicon Valley as a tech worker for 20 years. Oh, maybe this is why it resonated. I didn't know this. Yeah. So that's wild. So 20 years, so that means he joined, he went to Silicon Valley in 1981. That was probably when it was literally Silicon, you know, like making chips and everything. Then yes, worked there 20 years, opened a bakery.
在你这么说之前，我甚至都没想过这一点。是的，我想他在波特兰经营一家餐馆。没错。是的，你猜对了。他在波特兰经营一家面包店。而且实际上，在2001年开设那家面包店之前，他在硅谷当了20年科技工作者。哦，也许这就是为什么它能引起共鸣。我之前不知道这个。是的。所以这太疯狂了。所以20年，这意味着他加入，他是在1981年去的硅谷。那可能正是字面上的硅谷时期，你知道的，制造芯片什么的。然后是的，在那里工作了20年，开了一家面包店。
Good for him. Very cool. All right. So time for tool of the show. My tool of the show is this app called Pythagoria. I guess sticking with the Greco-Roman theme that I have going here. So Pythagoria is this game where you basically have to solve geometric puzzles. And so that sounds like it would be really boring, like, you know, doing math homework as a game or something. But they actually do a great job of making it really engaging. You know, one of the things that they do really nicely is,
祝贺他。非常酷。好吧，是时候迎来本期工具推荐了。我本期的工具推荐是一款名为Pythagoria的应用程序。我想延续我这里一直在搞的希腊罗马主题。所以Pythagoria是一个游戏，基本上你必须解决几何谜题。这听起来可能真的很无聊，就像把做数学作业当成游戏什么的。但他们确实在使其非常引人入胜方面做得很棒。你知道，他们做得很好的事情之一是，
you know, the game is played on this 16-point grid, or maybe, you know, one of the things that they do really nicely is, you know, the game is played on this, this 16 point grid, or maybe, you know, it's more than that. It's 36 point grid. So there's a six by six grid of dots. And so, you know, the first level is very simple. There's a dot on the left side, dot on the right side. They're like, you know, find the dot in the middle, you tap the middle of the screen, you move on. And then, you know, it kind of tells you, hey, you know, you have two dots, you know, make like an isosceles triangle. And so you can drag lines between the dots to make triangles, but you're restricted by these dots. And the dots, the fact that you can only draw a line either from dots to dots, or you can make new dots where two lines intersect, that's where it starts to get really complicated. So for example, there was one puzzle where you kind of needed a point that was
你知道，游戏是在这个16点网格上玩的，或者也许，你知道，他们做得很好的事情之一是，你知道，游戏是在这个，这个16点网格上玩的，或者也许，你知道，它不止于此。它是36点网格。所以有一个6x6的点网格。所以，你知道的，第一关非常简单。左边有一个点，右边有一个点。他们就像是，你知道的，找到中间的点，你点击屏幕中间，然后继续。然后，你知道的，它会告诉你，嘿，你知道的，你有两个点，你知道的，做一个等腰三角形。所以你可以在点之间拖动线来制作三角形，但你受到这些点的限制。这些点，你只能从点到点画一条线，或者你可以在两条线相交的地方创造新的点，这就是它开始变得非常复杂的地方。所以例如，有一个谜题，你需要一个点是
sort of in the middle of four points. So you needed a point where there wasn't one. And so what you have to do to solve that is you can just make a little X, right? So imagine your mind like four points, you know, in a square shape, right? And if you draw the two diagonals, now you have an X, right? And so then the middle of that X, you can actually tap that and now make a fifth point in the middle. And so you can now like when you get to the harder levels, now it really opens it up because you can really make a point anywhere as long as you can figure out how to get two lines to intersect at that place, right? So the hard puzzles start getting really hard where it's like, okay, I need to go to like seven
位于四个点的中间。所以你需要一个原本没有点的地方。所以你为了解决这个问题必须做的是，你可以画一个小X，对吧？所以想象你的脑海中有四个点，你知道的，呈正方形排列，对吧？如果你画两条对角线，现在你就有了一个X，对吧？然后那个X的中间，你实际上可以点击它，现在在中间创造第五个点。所以你现在可以，当你进入较难的关卡时，它真的打开了局面，因为你真的可以在任何地方创造一个点，只要你能弄清楚如何让两条线在那个地方相交，对吧？所以困难的谜题开始变得非常难，就像是，好吧，我需要去这两个点之间七十六分之几的位置。所以就像，我能画什么线来让它发生呢？所以它实际上真的很有趣，我的意思是，这是那种很难通过音频解释的事情，但我强烈推荐你去看看。另一件事是它是完全免费的，这是一个捐赠制的
sixteenths of the way between these two points. And so like, what lines can I draw to like make that happen? And so it's actually it's really fun i mean it's it's one of these things it's like very hard to explain you know audio um through audio but i highly recommend you check it out the other thing is it's completely free um it's a donation where um game so i went and gave them i think it's like a dollar or whatever that they're asking for but um but you can play the entire game cover to cover totally free no ads uh nothing like that and uh i found it really stimulating like the other thing is as soon as you get it right it kind of dings and you know you got it right you're not really guessing and so some of the levels you know i would stare
游戏，所以我去了，给了他们我认为是一美元或者他们要求的任何金额，但是，你可以从头到尾玩整个游戏，完全免费，没有广告，没有类似的东西。我发现它真的很刺激。另一件事是，一旦你做对了，它就会叮的一声响，你知道你做对了，你不是在瞎猜。所以有些关卡，你知道的，我会盯着它看，盯着它看，盯着它看，然后我差不多能发现，好吧，秘诀在这里。然后你掌握了那个秘诀，你就解开了谜题。这非常令人满足。我觉得他们在节奏把握上做得很好。像这样的游戏，很容易设计出一个极其困难的关卡，然后你就无法前进了，这真的很令人沮丧。他们在逐步增加难度方面做得很好。而且其中
at it stare at it stare at it and i kind of find out, okay, here's sort of the trick. And then you get that trick, you solve the puzzle. It's very satisfying. I felt like they did a good job with the pacing. A game like this, it's very easy to make a level that's extremely difficult, and then you just can't move on, and it's really frustrating. They did a good job of ramping up the difficulty. And one of the
他们为帮助掌握节奏而做的另一件事是，游戏分为各个章节，但章节的复杂度并不是递增的。它们只是不同的现象，几何现象。而且你实际上可以异步游玩所有章节。所以如果你在第二章卡住了，你就直接去第三章。所以我觉得这也是一个非常聪明的游戏设计，是的，绝对去看看，完全免费，所以没有什么可失去的。太棒了，这真的太酷了。所以现在你随身带着圆规和直尺，制作正十二边形，像所有人展示一切看起来都像是一个几何问题。这就像是，好吧，你知道这门扇门关不上，让我掏出Pythagoria，你知道的，这太棒了。我的工具是，我们以前可能把它作为工具推荐过，但那是Google Keep。
other things they did to help with the pacing is the game is broken down into chapters, but the chapters aren't in increasing complexity. They're just different phenomena, geometric phenomena. And you can actually play all the chapters asynchronously. So if you get stuck in chapter two, you just go to chapter three. So felt like that was uh also really clever game design and uh yeah definitely check it out totally free so there's nothing to lose awesome that's really cool so now you're going around with like a compass and ruler and making dodeca guns and like showing all your friends everything looks like a geometric problem it's like okay you know this door won't close let me pull out pythagoria you know that's awesome uh mine is we might have even had this as a tool
我觉得很多人可能以前听说过这个，但有些人可能没有，这是一种做笔记的方式。但我最近意识到Google Keep的力量在于坚持使用它，并记下相当于应用程序或网页上的便签（post-it notes）的内容，或者发送链接作为做书签的方式，放入图片，只是收集大量未组织的数据，然后能够搜索它，能够去到像日历日期这样的地方，你可以进行分类，甚至只是让它保持杂乱，然后随着时间把东西放在那里并积累起来。然后，你知道的，我身上发生了一件事，我想，我好像曾经写下过这个，或者我正在做一些
to show before but that is google keep um i feel a lot of people may have heard of this before but some some may have not and it's a way of doing note taking. But I think the power that I had recently realized about Google Keep is having sticking with it and using it and jotting what amounts to kind of like post it notes in the app or on the web or sending links as like a way to doing bookmarks and putting pictures in and just sort of gathering a lot of unorganized data and then just being able to be at search it to be able to go to like dates to be able to you can do categorization, but even just leaving it messy, and then putting stuff there over time and building it up. And then, you know, some something happened to me where I was like, I think I had written this down one time, or I was cooking some
晚饭。然后我就想，哦，我想我上次争论过要把温度设在多少度。就像，好吧，让我去看看。哦，是的，果然。我在这里做了一个笔记，因为我觉得这是我想记住的事情。所以只要把这些像笔记截图、食谱图片或链接的小东西放进去，以后任何时候我想弄清楚我曾知道但我不知道或找不到的事情时，第二次总是尽量确保把它放进去。因为如果你需要它，你知道的，两次，可能还会需要它。所以随着时间的推移不断积累，我认为有一些开源的
dinner. And I was like, Oh, I think I last time debated what temperature to put this at. And like, well, let me go see. Oh, yeah, sure enough. I, I took a note here cause it felt like something I'd want to remember. And so just putting these little like shots of a node or a picture recipe or a link and being able to find those things later, anytime where I try to figure out something that I knew and I, I don't, or couldn't find it, always try to make sure to go put it in there the second time. Cause if I needed it, you know, twice, probably going to need it again. And so building that up over time, I think there are some open source
或者人们使用的不同替代方案和其他平台。所以我的工具是Google Keep，谷歌允许你免费使用它。它带有所有传统的谷歌缺点，我猜。但这是一个优点。但是然后，你知道的——有广告还是没广告？
or different alternatives and other platforms that people use. So this is, my tool is Google Keep, which Google allows you to use for free. It comes with all the traditional Google cons, I guess. But that is a pro. But then, you know- Are there ads or no ads?
我想我没见过广告，但人们对谷歌普遍有一种又爱又恨的关系，我完全理解。所以不要在那里放任何你不愿意与谷歌分享的私人信息，我猜。但是，使用像这样的工具，我猜会是我的推荐，这是一个你可以用非常低的开销，没有超级结构，只是把你的信息放进去并让它积累的东西。我们讨论过电子邮件组织的重要性。如果你超级有组织，也许你不需要这个。我一开始就承认这是我需要做得更好的事情。但是，你知道，我认为在这里，这是我不会丢失那些小想法的一种方式。
I don't think I've seen ads, but people in general have a love hate relationship with Google, which I completely understand. And so don't put any private information there, I guess that you're not willing to share with Google. But, you know, using a tool like this, I guess would be my shout out, which is something where you can just very low overhead, not superstructure, just sort of put your information in and allow it to kind of accumulate. We talked about the importance of email organization. If you're super organized, maybe you don't need this. I already fessed up in the beginning that it's something I need to do better at. But, you know, I think here, this is a way for me to kind of not lose those little ideas.
是的。那你靠搜索来检索笔记吗？所以笔记不是层级结构的，对吧？不，我见过一些东西，一直对做那个很感兴趣。我觉得我对于层级结构或链接笔记之类的东西的犹豫在于，真的很酷，除了我知道我不会去放，我会更多地担心它在层级结构的哪个位置，因此如果我觉得它不适合层级结构，我就不会把东西放进去。这说得通。这里就像是我需要记录下来。是的，完全说得通。我想知道，也许我们可以自动生成层级结构？哦，你是什么意思？挺酷的。就像也许用某种无监督学习。
Yeah. Do you rely on search then to to retrieve the notes okay so the notes aren't like hierarchical or anything no i've seen stuff and always been intrigued about doing that i feel like the hesitation for me for hierarchical or like linked notes and stuff would be really cool except that i just know that i'm not gonna put i'm gonna worry more about where in the hierarchy goes and then therefore i'm not gonna put stuff in if i don't think it'll fit in the hierarchy that makes sense here it's like i need to just record it yep yep totally makes sense i wonder if like maybe we could automatically generate the hierarchy oh what do you mean pretty cool Like maybe with some unsupervised learning.
说到这里，要是我们今天的节目是关于……那是怎么发生的？Cluster my notes。Clustermynotes.com。那需要是——哦，我跟你说过这是一个稍微偏离的话题吗？然后我们将切入无监督学习。我做一个网站叫visual-if.com。那需要是——哦，我跟你说过这是一个稍微偏离的话题吗？然后我们将切入无监督学习。我做一个网站叫visual-if.com。
Speaking of which, if only our episode today was about... How did that happen? Cluster my notes. Clustermynotes.com. That needs to be... Oh, did I tell you it's a bit of a side topic? Then we'll jump in on supervised learning. I made a website called visual-if.com. That needs to be, oh, did I tell you it's a bit of a side topic? Then we'll jump in on supervised learning. I made a website called visual-if.com.
这个想法是UI非常笨拙，但它是一个互动小说游戏，在你玩游戏时它会运行DALL-E。所以，你知道，你输入，像，你知道的，你通过了介绍屏幕，它就像是向上看，向下看，电影，就像这些互动小说之一，比如Zork或Adventure，对吧？但任何时候有房间描述或任何东西，DALL-E都在后台运行，你会得到一些疯狂的艺术装置，无论那是什么。它确实让游戏变得非常有趣。如果你以前玩过互动小说，如果你以前玩过某个特定的游戏，
The idea is the UI is very clunky, but it's an interactive fiction game, but it runs Dolly as you're playing the game. So, you know, you type in, like, you know, you get past the intro screen, and it's like look up look down movies like one of these interactive fiction is like zork or adventure right but anytime there's a room description or anything um dolly is running in the background and you get like some crazy you know art installation of uh of whatever that is. And it really actually makes the games really fun. If you've played interactive fiction before, if you've played a particular game before,
你可以再玩一次，看看所有这些非常迷幻的图片。看看它是否与你第一次玩时脑海中想象的一致。我不确定我是否去对了地方。它要么做得好到让人困惑，要么我在某个其他随机人的网站上。所以Photopia是当你开始时运行的游戏……
you could play it again and just see all these really trippy pictures with it. See if it matches up with what you were envisioning when you played it the first time. I'm not sure if I went to the right spot or not. It's either really well done to be confusing or I'm on some other random person's website. So it's Photopia is the game that starts when you...
好吧，是的，是的，是的。是的，它说，你想要说明吗？是的，UI很烂。我承认。所以它说，你想要说明吗？你实际上必须点击那个，然后输入“否”或“是”。哦，好吧，好吧，它说，你要给我讲个故事吗？你实际上必须再次点击，然后现在你进入游戏了。我需要某种方式，也许我应该在游戏之前做一个小介绍
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes, it says, would you like instruction? Yes, the UI sucks. I'll admit it. So it says, would you like instruction? You actually have to click on that and then type no or yes. Oh, okay, okay says will you read me a story you have to actually click again and then now you're in the game i need some way to like maybe i should make like a little intro
屏幕，告诉人们他们将要经历什么。太棒了，这很酷。我的意思是，这些图片有点让人毛骨悚然，我不会撒谎，我得到的那些。是的，是的，就像有一个人滑雪什么的，至少我看到的是这样。但是的，这挺有趣的。我可能会尝试加倍投入，五倍投入。所以我发现人们并不真正理解如何使用那个产品。我只是问人们，他们说，我真的不明白我应该点击什么。但正如你在开发任何类型的产品时所做的那样，绝对地，你可以把它展示给你的朋友。你可以自己尝试。
screen before the game kind of tell people what they're in for nice this is cool i mean these pictures are like kind of creepy i'm not gonna lie the ones i'm getting yeah yeah it's like uh there's like a person skiing or something at least that's what i see um but yeah it's uh it was pretty pretty fun i might try and uh double down on that a five time so i found out people didn't really understand how to use that product. I just asked people and they're like, I don't really understand what I'm supposed to be clicking on. But as you kind of work on any type of product, definitely you can show it to your friends. You could try it out yourself.
但你最终会想把它展示给陌生人，对吧？正如我们在营销那一集里和凯文谈到的那样，对吧，最终你会把你构建的应用程序、网站或其他什么东西交给公众。你将无法真正站在他们肩膀后面去了解他们对它的想法。所以，绝对地，我们谈到了营销、调查和所有这一切。所以这里面也有整个人类要素。但你想做的另一件事是你想从数据中获得见解。所以理想情况下，你知道，想象一下如果你正在制作像这个应用程序这样的东西，例如，这个visual IF，你知道，我可以，我的意思是，我没有，我没有实现这个，但
But you will eventually want to show it to strangers, right? And as we talked about with Kevin in the marketing episode, right, eventually you're going to give your either app or website or whatever you're building to the public. And you're not going to be able to really look over their shoulder and find out what they were thinking about it. So, you know, definitely we talked about marketing and surveys and all of that. So there's a whole human element too. But another thing you want to do is you want to kind of gain insights from data. So ideally, you know, imagine if you're making like this app, for example, this visual IF, you know, I could, I mean, I didn't, I didn't implement this, but
你可以想象，我可以追踪人们移动鼠标的位置，或者他们点击了什么，或者如果他们点击了，他们在那个网站上花了多长时间。这些都可以进入某种报告，为我提供信息。然后我甚至可以更进一步，进行A/B测试。我可以尝试网站的新版本，看看它是否有改进，对吧？挑战在于，所有这些你将获得的数据都将是高度非结构化的，对吧？所以想象一下，它将从你在开发时可能做的打印日志（print logs）开始。所以，你知道，打印，（print，人点击了一个页面）或打印页面ID或打印，（print，人把鼠标移到页面底部），对吧？
you could imagine, you know, I could track where people are moving their mouse or what they're clicking on, or if they're clicking, how long they're spending on that site. And that could, you know, all go into some kind of report that would give me information. And then I could even go a step further and A, B test. I could try a new version of the site, see if it improves, right? The challenge is, you know, all of this data that you're going to get is going to be highly unstructured, right? So imagine, you know, it's going to start with these print logs that maybe you did when you were doing development. So, you know, print, you know, person clicked on a page or print the page ID or print, you know, person move the mouse to the bottom of the page, right?
而你必须以某种方式将其转化为你可以看到的东西，你可以查看的某种图表，并说，哦，这里有一些我可以做的事情来让事情变得更好。这就是，在宏观层面上，我们想要用无监督学习做的事情之一，就是获取大量的原始信息，就像，你知道的，反复使用的最大例子之一就是维基百科，你知道，获取整个维基百科，你能仅通过阅读——让计算机阅读整个维基百科——学到一些东西吗？所以这基本上就是无监督机器学习的全部内容。而且，是的，我认为，帕特里克，你把这个节目话题提上了桌面。我认为这是一个很棒的节目话题，也是我真正充满热情的领域。
And you have to somehow turn that into something that you can look at, some type of graph that you could look at and say, oh, here's some thing that I can do to make things better. And so that's, at a high level, one of the main things that we want to do with unsupervised learning is take you know a lot of raw information and like you know the the one of the biggest examples that is used repeatedly is wikipedia you know take all of wikipedia and can you just learn something from reading you know you're having a computer read all of wikipedia so that's basically what what unsupervised machine
是的，我的意思是，我认为就像杰森所说的那样，获取你的数据并帮助将其结构化，但我认为——我之前开了关于聚类的玩笑——我觉得有时，杰森是个机器学习从业者，比方说，那是他的行业。我不是。所以通常我尽量不做，不是因为我不知道那是什么或者做不了，而是因为它伴随着某些，老实说，我不知道，期望。所以当我着手工作时，我和摆在面前的数据以及手头任务的参与模式
learning is all about and uh yeah i think pat I think Patrick, you brought this show topic up to the table. I think it's a great show topic and something that I am really passionate about. Yeah, I mean, I think like Jason was saying, this taking your data and sort of like helping to structure it but i think and i made the joke about about clustering earlier i feel that sometimes um jason is a machine learning let's say practitioner right like that's that's his trade i'm not so in general i try not to do it not because i don't know what it is or can't do it but just because it comes with certain i don't know honestly expectations and so when i set out to do work it's like the engagement model I have with the data that I have in front of me and with the task at hand
与杰森作为机器学习从业者可能会有的情况有点不同。与此同时，我认为这个领域在某些部分有很多重叠，在机器学习从业者和——我只是在表达，我不知道是不是有更好的词——和其他人之间。所以我想有些事情，比如聚类，数据中可能存在特征，或者甚至可能已经有数字，你知道的，你沿着多个维度拥有，你知道，甚至只是两三个维度，如果你将它们聚类在一起并观察它们，那已经相当有帮助了。你可能会说，那不是机器学习。那不是，你知道，没有机器学习。那不是，你知道，没有神经网络。没有，你知道，随便什么。但我认为这没关系。我认为有些事情，你将回归（regression）拟合到你的数据中，并试图说，
is a bit different than Jason, Jason might have as a machine learning practitioner. The same time, I think this area in parts has a lot of overlap between and I'm just making I don't know if there's probably a better word, but sort of machine learning practitioners, and sort of other folks. And so I think there are things like, for example, like clustering, where there may be features of your data or heck, there might even already be numbers that, you know, you have along multiple dimensions, you know, just even two or three dimensions, where if you clustered them together and looked at them, that would already be quite helpful. And you may say, well, that's not machine learning. That's not, you know, there's not machine learning. That's not, you know, there's no neural network. There's no, you know, whatever. But I think that's okay. I think things where you're fitting a, you know, a regression to your data and trying to say,
你知道，嘿，看，这里有数字，我正在把一条线拟合到它上面。所以我可以思考下一个数字会是什么，或者数字之间会是什么，或者超出我拥有的最后一个数据点，对吧？我认为这些是你在这其中有很多重叠并了解这些事情并思考它们的事情。工具箱里又多了一个工具。我们一直在谈论这个。所以我很高兴讨论其中一些事情，因为我认为它们中的许多甚至对那些不称自己为机器学习从业者的人也很有价值，但对于任何拥有数据的人——这往往是很多人，或者大多数人都有一定数量的数据并试图使用它们——以及组织、削减数据、平滑数据、思考数据的各种方式，所有这些都有价值。对，没错。是的。所以，想象一下，你有很多关于访问你网站的人的数据。
you know, hey, look, there's numbers here, and I'm fitting a line to it. So I can think about what the next number would be, or between numbers or out past the last data point I have, right? I think those are kinds of things where you are overlapping in a lot of this and learning about those things and thinking about them. And there's another tool in the toolbox. We talk about that all the time. And so I'm pretty excited to talk about some of these things because I think a lot of them have value even to people who wouldn't call themselves machine learning practitioners, but anyone who has data, which tends out to be a lot of people, or most people have some amount of data that are trying to work with and ways of organizing, you know, cutting that data down, smoothing the data, thinking about the data, all those kinds of things. Yeah, right. Yeah. So I mean, imagine like you have a bunch of data around, you know, people who visit your website.
对吧。所以你想建立，你知道，聚类，你想建立某种群组（cohorts）。例如，你可能会了解到，不知何故，围绕年龄有很多特征。所以就像访问你网站的人要么，你知道的，真的很年轻，要么由于某种原因真的很老。所以也许他们来是有两个不同的原因。你必须弄清楚那部分。但聚类将通过观察质心（centroids）。质心是你开发的聚类的中心，可以为你提供大量的信息。例如，你可能有很多不同的特征，然后你可能会做聚类，这基本上是说对于每个数据点，数据点将类似于一组特征。所以也许数据点是一个人，他
Right. And so you want to set up, you know, clusters, you want to set up kind of cohorts. For example, you might learn that there's somehow like there's a lot of identity around age. So it's like the people visiting your website are either, you know, really young or really old for whatever reason. And so maybe they're coming for two different reasons. You have to figure that part out. But clustering will kind of looking at the centroids. The centroids are the centers of the clusters that you develop can give you a lot of information. So for example, you might have a whole bunch of different features, and then you might do clustering, which basically says for each of the data points, and a data point would be sort of like a set of features. So maybe a data point is a person who's
对的。因此你想建立，你知道的，聚类，你想建立各种同类群组。例如，你可能会发现某种程度上，年龄周围存在很多身份特征。所以就像访问你网站的人要么，你知道的，非常年轻，要么由于某种原因非常年老。因此，也许他们来这里有两个不同的原因。你必须弄清楚这一点。但聚类将类似于观察质心。质心是你开发的聚类的中心，可以为你提供大量信息。因此，例如，你可能会有大量不同的特征，然后你可能会进行聚类，这基本上意味着对于每个数据点，数据点有点像一组特征。所以也许数据点是一个
come to play your game and a set of features about them. Like how do you describe this person, right? And so then after you've done, you're finished with a clustering algorithm. Now each person, they're going to be assigned to one cluster. If it's a hard clustering, if it's a soft clustering, then they could be assigned to like some mixture of clusters, right? But that's neither here nor there. So now you can look at this at this sort of like these these clusters that people are assigned to. And you could find the center of them. In other words, given this group of people who are all assigned to cluster A, you know, what is the center point there? So what is like the person who would be most aligned with cluster A, like this hypothetical person who just perfectly lands in the middle of the cluster. And you say, okay, this is sort of an archetype. There's something unique about this group of people. You can also do this with faces if you're trying to do face recognition, or even if you're trying to do object recognition, you can even do clustering on images and say like, i have this huge bank of images and they're falling into
来运行你的游戏以及关于它们的一系列特征。就像你如何描述这个人，对吧？然后当你完成聚类算法之后。现在每个人，他们都会被分到一个聚类中。如果是硬聚类，如果是软聚类，那么他们可能会被分到一些聚类的混合中，对吧？但这其实并不重要。所以现在你可以看看这种人们被分配到的聚类。你可以找到它们的中心。换句话说，考虑到这群都被分配到A聚类的人，你知道，那里的中心点是什么？所以，谁是最符合A聚类的人，就像这个完美落在聚类中间的假设人物。你说，好吧，这算是一个原型。这群人有某种独特之处。如果你在做人脸识别，你也可以用这个来处理人脸，甚至如果你在尝试做物体识别，你甚至可以对图像进行聚类，然后说，我有这个庞大的图像库，它们落入
one of several categories so i think you know clustering has uh yeah it's been used for for tons of different things you can also then you know do machine learning on top of the clusters what have you used clusters for in your your work yeah I think like one of the things that came up recently is we noticed that, which I guess like just thinking about your data is like we were doing some processing and sometimes certain configurations of input were causing like the data to take a lot longer than other configurations. Sorry, speaking vague, but whatever. And so we were trying to kind of understand like, is there a difference or the features in one? And so this what you kind of alluded to, it's exactly right, which is, hey, we have a whole bunch of measurements, like the size of the input data, the like, let's just say it was text, right? Like, how many characters are there? How many lines are there? You know, how many punctuation marks would there be, right? Things which we could kind of look and say, hey, is there something about this that's making the processing take longer or not? And once we sort of like, you know, kind of started plotting it out and saying, okay, hang on,
几个类别中的一个，所以我认为你知道，聚类有——是的，它被用于各种各样不同的事情，然后你也可以（你知道）在聚类之上做机器学习，你用过聚类来做过什么吗？是的，我想最近出现的一件事情是，我们注意到——我想这就像思考你的数据一样——我们当时在做一些处理，有时某些输入配置会导致数据处理花费比其他配置长得多的时间。抱歉，说得有点含糊，但无所谓。所以我们试图去理解，一个里面是否有差异或特征？所以这正是你刚才所暗示的，完全正确，也就是说，嘿，我们有一大堆测量指标，比如输入数据的大小，比如，我们假设它是文本，对吧？比如，有多少个字符？有多少行？你知道，会有多少个标点符号，对吧？我们可以查看并说，嘿，这里面有什么东西让处理时间变长了吗？一旦我们开始把它们绘制出来并说，好吧，等等，
let's look at what the clusters are of these like sort of easy inputs and hard inputs. And like, what, what? Oh, okay. Well, look, these hard inputs all have you know a lot of extra punctuation in them and then you know realizing that the processing we were doing was going to cost a lot more when that happened right but we didn't kind of it was vague enough that it's it's a bit difficult to uh sort of know that in advance and just look at your code and say hey actually i see here we do all this extra work in punctuation. It was the sort of like second order effect that was causing it. And so by doing this clustering, and just looking at the results and saying, oh, look, these things are different than those things
让我们来看看这些简单输入和困难输入究竟属于什么聚类。然后，哦，原来如此。看，这些困难输入都有很多额外的标点符号，然后意识到我们正在做的处理在那种情况下会消耗更多的成本，对吧？但我们之前没有——它太模糊了，以至于很难提前知道这一点，然后去看看你的代码说，嘿，实际上我看到这里我们在标点符号上做了所有这些额外的工作。这是一种导致该问题的二阶效应。因此，通过这种聚类，只需观察结果并说，哦，看，这些东西跟那些东西不同，
allowed us to kind of say, hey, up front, let's check for that and handle them specially, or maybe decompose them further or do something special. And so that's what we use Zipf. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, one area where you see a lot of clustering is around log ingest and log reading. So imagine you have a website. The website has a MySQL database. It's got servers, backend servers.
让我们能够说，嘿，我们在最开始就检查出这种情况并进行特殊处理，或者也许进一步拆解它们，或者做一些特殊处理。这就是我们使用Zipf的原因。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，你经常看到聚类的一个领域是在日志摄取和日志读取方面。所以想象你有一个网站。这个网站有一个MySQL数据库。它有服务器，后端服务器。
It's got the JavaScript on the client. And all these things are generating logs, right? Your server, your database is generating all these logs. Like, oh, I'm getting full up or, oh, the utilization is too high. Actually, to be honest, have you ever looked at a database log, like a MySQL log? No. I've never done either. I just assume it works. it shows that we're terrible
它有客户端上的JavaScript。所有这些东西都在生成日志，对吧？你的服务器，你的数据库正在生成所有这些日志。比如，哦，我快满了，或者，哦，利用率太高了。说实话，你曾经看过数据库日志吗，比如MySQL日志？没有。我也从来没看过。我只假设它能正常工作。这表明我们是糟糕的
dbas but you know it's generating a ton of logs and you know if your database like goes down or all of a sudden it takes i i do have some uh actually like there's a lot of popular websites that are only run by like 10 people you know what i mean like or i think craigslist is famous for having just extremely small staff for such a popular website. But eventually, you'll run into this where your site just doesn't load. And you're going to have to go step through all of these. So you look at the client, say, OK, the client's fine. You go to the server logs.
数据库管理员，但你知道，它生成了大量的日志，如果你的数据库宕机了，或者突然间需要——我确实有一些——实际上有很多热门网站只由10个人运营，你知道我的意思吗？或者我认为Craigslist以拥有如此小的工作人员来支撑如此热门的网站而闻名。但最终，你会遇到这种情况，你的网站就是加载不出来了。然后你必须逐步排查所有这些日志。所以你看看客户端，说，好吧，客户端没问题。你转去看服务器日志。
And it just says, it's just waiting on the database access. Wait database results. Then you go to the database. It's like you know, it's just waiting on the database access, wait database results. And you go to the database. It's like, yeah, utilization is 100 percent and you have to end up doing something. Right. So you're getting all these logs. A lot of it is code that you haven't written. Right.
它上面只写着，它在等待数据库访问。等待数据库结果。然后你转到数据库。就像你知道的，它只是在等待数据库访问，等待数据库结果。然后你转到数据库。就像，是的，利用率是100%，你最终必须做点什么。没错。所以你收到了所有这些日志。其中很多都是你没有编写的代码。没错。
Because there are logs from programs that you're using and you need some way to say, OK, can I separate the signal from the noise right like like is there like like is this log actually interesting um and and actually a lot of these systems like sentry and bug snag and these other systems use clustering so what they'll do is they'll take every log line and uh they'll do what's called an embedding which we can get to later but but they'll basically take every log line and turn it into a point in some space so imagine some cube but it's like a hypercube it's like a you know a 200 dimensional cube or something actually we talked about it in my mind yeah i've got the 200 dimensional cube i'm picturing it in my mind that's not like magnus carlson plays chess or
因为有来自你正在使用的程序的日志，你需要某种方法来表明，好，我能否将信号从噪声中分离出来，比如——比如这个日志真的很有趣吗？——事实上，许多这样的系统，比如Sentry、Bugsnag和其他系统，都使用了聚类。所以它们会做的是，它们会获取每一行日志，然后进行所谓的嵌入（Embedding），我们稍后可以讨论这个，但它们基本上会获取每一行日志，并将其转化为某个空间中的一个点。所以想象一下某种立方体，但它是一个超立方体，就像一个（你知道）200维的立方体之类。实际上我们在我的脑海里讨论过它。是的，我脑子里有那个200维的立方体，我在脑海中想象着它。这不像 Magnus Carlsen 下国际象棋或者
whatever you know but uh we talked to ito liberty about embeddings on on that show um and so yeah you have this big cube and you've you've figured out a way to take these lines of log and put them in this cube, right? So if I have a log line that's printing every second, that's like, you know, things are good. You know, it's like 1901, things are good. 1902, things are good. That's going to look the same, right?
随便什么，你知道，但我们跟 Ito Liberty 在那一期节目中讨论了关于嵌入的内容……所以，是的，你有这个巨大的立方体，并且你想出了一种方法，把这些日志行放进这个立方体里，对吧？所以，如果我有一行日志，每秒都在打印，内容类似于，事情进展顺利。你知道，比如1901年，事情进展顺利。1902年，事情进展顺利。这看起来是一样的，对吧？
It's always going to say things are good and then some kind of date, right? And so since it's so similar, and even the date, the number, the timestamp is also kind of date, right? And so since it's so similar, and even the date, the number, the timestamp is also kind of similar, those will likely end up close together in this space, right, once you've done this embedding. And so you can throw all these logs into that space and then do clustering. And chances are the, you know, things are good message will get its own cluster if there's so many of them and then you could just throw them all away all right uh you could also do things like say okay this line of log isn't even really near any of the clusters so it must be something
它总是会说事情进展顺利，然后带某种日期，对吧？而且由于它们如此相似，甚至日期、数字、时间戳也都有点相似，一旦你完成了这个嵌入，这些日志最终很可能会在这个空间里靠得很近，对吧？所以你可以把所有这些日志扔进那个空间，然后进行聚类。如果“事情进展顺利”这条消息有那么多，那么它极可能会拥有自己的聚类，然后你就可以把它们全部扔掉。好吧，你还可以做一些事情，比如，这行日志甚至跟任何聚类都不太贴近，所以它一定是很
pretty unique pretty special um so maybe this one i should you should send an alert or something like that. And that's called outlier detection. And that's also, it's a really hard problem, but there's a bunch of great libraries. There's PyOD. There's a bunch of great libraries for outlier detection. And they're all kind of, it's all very related to clustering. So what are some other examples of unsupervised learning? Yeah, I think a lot of these words like unsupervised learning, reinforcement learning, a lot of them have become kind of really nebulous, right? As all of these fields have kind of like overflowed, right? But now there's the hot thing is sort of self-supervised
独特、很特别的东西，所以也许这个我应该——你应该发送一个警报之类的。这被称为异常检测。这也是一个非常困难的问题，但有很多优秀的库。有PyOD。有很多用于异常检测的优秀库。它们都在某种程度上与聚类密切相关。那么，还有哪些无监督学习的其他例子呢？是的，我认为许多这样的词，比如无监督学习、强化学习，随着所有这些领域的相互交融，它们在某种程度上都变得非常模糊不清，对吧？但现在最热门的东西是某种自监督
learning. And the idea with that is it's still unsupervised in the sense that you don't have a human... Actually, we should probably talk about that. So supervised learning is typically where you have a human in the loop. So imagine if I'm playing chess and I train some model to mimic my moves. So if I move the pawn, then I tell some model, hey, when you see this board, I want you to move the same pawn to the same place. And so it's supervised. I'm a supervisor, right? And it is just trying to mimic this, right? Now unsupervised would be a little different.
学习。其核心思想是，它仍然是无监督的，在这个意义上，你不需要人类……实际上，我们大概应该讨论一下这个。因此，监督学习通常是指有真人参与其中的学习。想象一下，如果我在下国际象棋，我训练某种模型来模仿我的走法。如果我移动了兵，然后我告诉某个模型，嘿，当你看到这个棋盘时，我希望你把相同的兵移动到相同的地方。所以这是有监督的。我是监督者，对吧？它只是在试图模仿这个，对吧？现在，无监督会有所不同。
Unsupervised would be where, for example, you might train an autoencoder. So you might say, here's a picture of a chess board. I want this algorithm to embed that picture. So find a function that takes this picture of this chessboard and creates a point for that picture somewhere in this space. And then I want another function that takes that point and creates the picture again, right? And so you're going from the picture to the point back to the original picture. And so when you do this and you train this model, it ends up having to represent, you know, the essence of that picture in that point.
无监督是指，例如，你可能会训练一个自编码器（Autoencoder）。所以你可能会说，这里有一张国际象棋棋盘的照片。我希望这个算法将该照片进行嵌入。即找到一个函数，它获取这张棋盘照片，并在该空间的某个地方为该照片创建一个点。然后我希望另一个函数获取那个点并再次生成照片，对吧？所以你从照片到点，再回到原始照片。当你这样做并训练这个模型时，它最终必须在该点中表示出那张照片的精髓。
So, for example, let's say all of my pictures have the same chessboard and it's on a black table, right? And it's the same camera setup. It's like a tripod. So it's very reliable, very stationary. It's all pictures of this black table with this chessboard on it. So it can just recover the black table without needing any extra information right so because every single point that we draw in that cube when you go back to draw the picture you're going to need that black table and so that's where like this really powerful compressive ability comes in so you actually know, the points now don't need to differentiate based on the table. They're all going to have the table in it. And so, you know,
所以，举个例子，假设我所有的照片都有相同的棋盘，并且它放在一张黑色的桌子上，对吧？而且是相同的相机设置。就像一个三脚架。所以它是非常可靠、非常静止的。这全都是这张黑色的桌子以及上面放着棋盘的照片。所以它可以直接恢复出黑色的桌子，而不需要任何额外的信息，对吧？因为我们在那个立方体中绘制的每一个点，当你返回去绘制照片时，你都需要那张黑色的桌子，所以这就是这种非常强大的压缩能力发挥作用的地方——所以你其实知道，
if two points are close together, then that means that the two images they generate must be similar, even given the similarities that there are broadly, like they must be even hyperlocal. They must be similar. Otherwise, those two points will get pulled apart. And so the way the autoencoder works is, you know, you generate the chessboard. It's not going to look exactly right. So you have some error. And then you say, OK, you know, this pixel is like too dark or you drew a pawn here and
现在的这些点不需要根据桌子来进行区分。它们都会包含桌子。所以，你知道，
you really shouldn't have it's empty. And so you, you know, given that you know the right here and you really shouldn't have it's empty and so you you know given that you know the right answer you just tell the model hey here's the right answer adjust yourself and it will figure out how to use that volume that embedding volume in the best way or in a good way to be able to generate all of those pictures not just one of them does that make sense yeah i think so i mean that was that was pretty deep but here i guess the when we were talking about like clustering you don't necessarily like you mentioned they're like the right answer there's no way to necessarily feed back so you're like you might as a human tune something or do something like the number
如果两个点靠得很近，那就意味着它们生成的两幅图像必然是相似的，即使考虑到那些广泛存在的相似性，它们也必须是超局部的。它们必须是相似的。否则，这两个点就会被拉开。所以自编码器的运作方式是，你知道，你生成了棋盘。它看起来不会完全正确。所以你会产生一些误差。然后你说，好吧，你知道，这个像素太暗了，或者你在这里画了一个兵，
of clusters but and there may be algorithms you do that there's really no necessarily right answer when you're talking about it's still unsupervised but this sort of like auto encoding you're kind of giving a problem constricting the amount of information that can be shared between sort of like the left half and the right half and then trying to say like you need to simplify down to a representation and then reconstitute that representation back to the original and then look and compare the two. So you have a well-defined metric for saying, like, hey, how well did you do at your task? And so you algorithmically are supervising it. But as a human, you're not sort of like at each interval sort of like labeling something or giving a behavior to emulate.
而实际上它本该是空的，不应该有。所以，你知道，鉴于你知道正确答案，你只需告诉模型，嘿，这里是正确答案，调整一下你自己，它就会弄清楚如何以最佳方式或好方式利用那个容量、那个嵌入容量，从而能够生成所有这些照片，而不仅仅是其中一张。这说得通吗？是的，我想是的。我的意思是，那确实挺深奥的，但在这里，我想当我们谈论聚类时，你不一定像你提到的那样有正确答案，没有办法必然地进行反馈，所以作为一个人类，你可能会调整某些东西或者做一些事情，比如聚类的数量
Yeah, that's right. And the reason why all of this kind of comes together is, you know, clustering, you know, imagine you're looking at a group of people, like you're in a helicopter, and you're looking down at a stadium full of people or something, or you're looking at a football game or something, right? There's little dots, like they're maybe the size of ants or something running around on this football field so like when you cluster you're going to be using sort of the geometry of the field right so if somebody is twice as far away then that really has a big impact on whether they're going to be in that cluster or not with these other group of people right right? And so for all of clustering, you need to have a space that's pretty uniform. So like, for example, let's say you fed a bunch of features into some clustering.
，并且可能有相应的算法让你去这么做，但当你讨论它时，其实不一定有绝对正确的答案，它仍然是无监督的。但这种自编码就像是你给它出了一个问题，限制了可以在左半部分和右半部分之间共享的信息量，然后试图说，你需要简化为一个表征，然后再把这个表征还原成原始数据，接着进行观察并对两者进行比较。因此，你有一个定义明确的衡量指标来评估：嘿，你在你的任务上做得怎么样。因此，你在算法层面上监督着它。但作为人类，你并不是在每个间隔都去给某些东西打标签或赋予要模仿的行为。
And one of your features is person's age in milliseconds. And the other feature is person's height in meters, right? Well, like one is enormous, right? Your age in milliseconds, it's a huge number. And so the clustering algorithm will totally ignore the other feature because your height in meters is, you know, I don't know from, you know, I guess 0.5 to three or something. You know, it's such a small range.
是的，没错。所有这一切之所以能结合在一起的原因在于，你知道，聚类，想象你在观察一群人，就像你在直升机上，正俯视着一个坐满人的体育场之类，或者你在看一场足球比赛之类的，对吧？上面有小小的点，它们可能只有蚂蚁那么大，在足球场上跑来跑去。所以当你进行聚类时，你会用到球场的几何形状，对吧？如果某个人远了两倍，那真的会对他们是否会和这群其他人分在同一个聚类中产生很大的影响，对吧？没错。因此，对于所有的聚类，你需要有一个相当均匀的空间。所以，举个例子，假设你把一堆特征输入到某种聚类中。
Actually, I guess there's nobody nine feet tall, but anyways, so you're hiding, I'm trying to figure out the tallest person in the world is what, eight foot? Anyway, so your range is tiny. It's like three units, right? But your age in milliseconds is enormous. And so the clustering algorithm will just cluster ages
而你的其中一个特征是人的年龄（以毫秒为单位）。另一个特征是人的身高（以米为单位），对吧？好吧，其中一个特征非常巨大，对吧？你的年龄以毫秒为单位是一个极其巨大的数字。因此，聚类算法会完全忽略另一个特征，因为你以米为单位的身高，你知道，我不清楚，从0.5到3或者其他什么。你知道，它的范围太小了。
until you're, you know, not pay attention to the other one. And so, you know, if you're trying to cluster images or text or some of these things, you quickly run into this problem where the thing isn't geometric. And so the clustering can't really take into account different dimensions in a way that's fair. And so the nice thing about this auto-encoding is the way that the loss kind of propagates backwards from the correct chessboard to that latent space to the input chessboard, the way that those dots move and the way that the things kind of shake up ends up
事实上，我想大概没有人能有九英尺高吧，但无论如何，你的身高范围微乎其微。大概只有三个单位，对吧？但你的年龄以毫秒为单位却是巨大的。因此，聚类算法只会对年龄进行聚类，
creating like really nice spaces where all the dimensions have relatively the same importance. This is interesting. So yeah, so you're training both halves, but you may be taking, I guess you were calling it like the latent space in the middle, the encoded thing, and using it as input to other parts of your system
而不会关注另一个特征。所以，如果你试图对图像、文本或其他一些东西进行聚类，你很快就会遇到这样一个问题：事物本身不是几何的。因此，聚类无法以公平的方式真正考虑到不同的维度。而这种自编码的好处在于，损失从正确的棋盘向后传播到那个潜在空间（Latent Space），再传播到输入棋盘的方式，这些点移动的方式以及事物被重组的方式，最终
or sort of like clustering in that sort of more well-formed space so that you can say things about it even if you never end up reconstituting like there's really no reason for you to get back to the original chessboard like you had it as input like you could just use it you didn't really need that part but it helps you to get that middle part that you could then use to do clustering on. Yeah, exactly. So now let's imagine we have a bunch of people who go to your website, or we could even stick with the football analogy. We have a bunch of football players, right? And we have a bunch of statistics about them. And these statistics are all over the place. Some of them are important. Some of them aren't
创造出了非常棒的空间，其中所有维度都具有相对相同的相对重要性。这很有趣。所以，是的，你在训练两半部分，但你可能会取——我猜你刚才管它叫中间的潜在空间，即被编码的东西——并把它作为输入传给你系统的其他部分，
important. The units are all different. And so if we just feed these players into some clustering algorithm, then it's going to have a really hard time. Maybe basketball. I know more about basketball. So basketball, people score a lot of points, but their height in feet, let's say and in decimal feet is going to be relatively small so all my score you know 20 30 points but they're only like seven feet tall and so the so you have like different scales there as well right um you know or assists or rebounds um you know number of minutes played um you know and so all of these have different, you know, and even slight differences in units can really matter. You could do some type of, let's say, contrastive learning, which is a self-supervised approach. So you might say, here's a list of players who I felt played very similarly.
或者在那种结构更完善的空间中进行聚类，这样即使你最终从未还原成原始棋盘（就像你把它作为输入时那样），你也可以对它做出一些论断。你其实完全没有理由非得回到最初的棋盘——就像你把它当成输入那样——你完全可以直接使用它，你其实并不真正需要后面那部分，但它能帮你得到中间那部分，然后你就可以用它来做聚类。是的，完全正确。现在让我们想象一下，我们有一群访问你网站的人，或者我们也可以坚持用足球的比喻。我们有一群足球运动员，对吧？我们有关于他们的一堆统计数据。而这些统计数据到处都是。其中一些很重要。有些并不
So I could come and say, okay, you know, Shaquille O'Neal and Dikembe Mutombo, they're both centers, really tall, strong people who just can, are strong enough that they can just push their way through and dunk the basketball, right? Those people are very similar. So I'm going to pull these two people together. So, you know, whatever their features are, you know, they're going to, we're going to create sort of a point for these two people based on their features. And then we're going to say these two points need to be closer together. Then I'm going to take, you know, Shaquille O'Neal and like Anthony Hardaway. And so Anthony Hardaway is like a three point shooter, like small person, like for basketball standpoint, small person who goes and shoots shots from far away. So these people clearly are
重要。它们的单位全都不一样。所以如果我们直接把这些球员输入到某个聚类算法中，那它就会非常艰难。也许换成篮球。我对篮球更了解一些。所以在篮球中，人们会得很多分，但他们的身高（以英尺为单位，比如带小数的英尺）相对会比较小。所以我的所有得分，你知道，有20、30分，但他们只有大约7英尺高。因此，你那里也有不同的量级，对吧？你知道，或者助攻、篮板，你知道，出场分钟数，你知道，所有这些都有不同的量级，甚至单位上的微小差异其实都很重要。你可以做某种——比方说——对比学习（Contrastive Learning），这是一种自监督方法。所以你可能会说，这里有一份我认为表现非常相似的球员名单。
far apart. You might even actually just use the positions, right? You might say, okay, all the centers should be close together. And then take two people who are from two different positions, they should be far apart. And so in this way, you're not, it's not supervised learning because you're not saying, okay, you know, Shaquille should be right here or, you know, Shaquille should make like this many points or something. You're basically saying, you know, these people should be closer together. These pairs should be close together. These pairs should be far apart. And it's contrastive learning. It's self-supervised if you can automate all of that without a human in the loop. Basketball is a weird example because at some point a human did decide
所以我可以过来并说，好吧，你知道，沙奎尔·奥尼尔（Shaquille O'Neal）和迪肯贝·穆托姆博（Dikembe Mutombo），他们都是中锋，个子非常高，身体强壮的人，他们强大到足以依靠身体强行挤过去并把篮球扣进篮筐，对吧？这些人非常相似。所以我要把这两个人拉到一起。所以，无论他们的特征是什么，我们将根据他们的特征为这两个人创建一个点。然后我们要说，这两个点需要靠得更近。接下来我要拿走沙奎尔·奥尼尔和像安东尼·哈达威（Anthony Hardaway）这样的人。安东尼·哈达威就像是一个三分射手，身材较小的人——从篮球的角度来看——个子较小，会跑去投远距离球。所以这些人显然是
you should be a center, right? So maybe not the best example, but you could even imagine like doing contrastive learning on images. So you could say, here's a bunch of images that are on the same website. And because just by virtue of them being on the same website, they should be pulled together. And then here's two images from two different websites. They should be pushed apart. And so if you do this and you have a low learning rate, because that's going to be a weak signal, right? But if you do this and you have a ton of images and you've scraped a lot of the internet,
相距甚远的。你甚至可能直接使用位置信息，对吧？你可能会说，所有的中锋都应该靠得很近。然后挑出两个属于不同位置的人，他们应该相距甚远。通过这种方式，它不是监督学习，因为你并没有说，好吧，沙奎尔应该在这个位置，或者沙奎尔应该得这么多分之类的。你基本上是在说，这些人应该更靠近。这些对子应该靠得近。这些对子应该相距远。这就是对比学习。如果你能在没有人类参与的情况下将所有这些自动化，它就是自监督的。篮球是个奇怪的例子，因为在某个时刻，人类确实决定了
you'll end up with an embedding that's that's really powerful and so contrastive learning and auto encoding where you feed in the same thing that you're trying to predict are two ways of generating like really nice spaces that then you can do clustering and other things with this is is awesome. So we were sort of giving examples and sort of saying the algorithmic approach, I guess, to doing this. What are some applications of what people do with the... I mean, we talked about outlier detection for logs.
你应该去打中锋，对吧？所以也许这不是最好的例子，但你甚至可以想象对图像进行对比学习。所以你可以说，这里有一堆在同一个网站上的图像。仅仅因为它们在同一个网站上这一事实，它们就应该被拉近。然后这里有来自两个不同网站的两张图像。它们应该被推开。如果你这样做并且使用较低的学习速率，因为那将是一个微弱的信号，对吧？但如果你这样做，并且你拥有大量的图像，而且你抓取了互联网的大部分内容，
I think that was a good one. We were talking about classifying things. What are some other examples of applications of this process? Yeah, I mean, you know, all of the language processing is now pretty much done in this way. So, for example, you know, it used to be that if you wanted to train a model, let's say, to translate French to English, you know, you would have to pay people to, you know, manually translate tons and tons of things, like literally millions of sentences. And then you would train, you know, your model on these sentences. And you would have some translation that just goes from French to English, right? It's extremely expensive. Right. So now what they do is, you know, they will do what's called a word embedding.
你最终会得到一个非常强大的嵌入。所以对比学习和自编码（你输入你正试图预测的相同事物）是生成非常nice的空间的两种方法，你可以随后用它来进行聚类和其他操作。这太棒了。所以我们刚才一直在举例并阐述完成这件事的算法方法。人们用这些技术做了哪些应用呢？我的意思是，我们讨论了针对日志的异常检测。
So basically, there's a whole bunch of different ways to do this. So one way would be a self-supervised approach where you say, given all the words up to this word. So, you know, like what was it called? Like the brown. What is that one that's like you see all the words up to this word so um you know like what was it called like the brown what is that one that's like you see all the time brown fox jumps over the lazy dog yeah that's it okay so you say like i didn't know this that the reason that's a sentence is because for handwriting is it uses it's like the shortest sentence that uses all the letters of the alphabet or a very short sentence which uses all the letters of the alphabet what a very short sentence, which uses all the letters of the alphabet. So it was a penmanship test.
我认为那是个很好的例子。我们讨论了对事物进行分类。这个过程的应用还有哪些其他例子？是的，我的意思是，你知道，所有的语言处理现在几乎都是以这种方式完成的。所以，举个例子，你知道，过去如果你想训练一个模型，比方说把法语翻译成英语，你知道，你必须花钱雇人手动翻译大量的东西，比如字面意义上数百万个句子。然后你会在这些句子上训练你的模型。你就会有一种直接从法语翻译到英语的翻译器，对吧？这是极其昂贵的。没错。所以现在他们所做的是，你知道，他们会做所谓的词嵌入（Word Embedding）。
I never knew that. I learned that like a week ago. What? Shut the front door. Wait a minute. And then I was like sitting there counting them all. Yeah. Nope.
所以基本上，有各种各样不同的方法来做到这一点。其中一种方法是自监督方法，你可能会说，给定这个词之前的所有词。所以，你知道，它叫什么来着？就像那个“棕色的”。那个总是能看到的句子是什么来着——棕色的狐狸跳过了懒狗。是的，就是那个。好吧，所以你说——我以前不知道这个，那句话之所以存在，是因为在手写练习中，它用到了字母表中的所有字母，或者说是一句用到了字母表中所有字母的非常简短的句子。一句话用到了字母表中的所有字母。所以它是一个书法测试。
Nope. Yep. They're all there. Wow. Oh my gosh. My mind is totally blown. I feel like that. Have you seen that video where the guy pretends to do a magic trick and he takes the straw
我从来不知道这一点。我大概是一周前才学到的。什么？关上大门（难以置信）。等一下。然后我当时就坐在那里数它们。是的。没有。
and he has his friend like put the straw behind the other guy's back and it blows his mind. Anyways. Yeah. That's me right now. So, wow, that's freaking awesome. Okay. So, so is what the quick brown fox or no, the quick, I thought the dog was brown. The brown fox jumps over the lazy dog.
没有。是的。它们都在那儿。哇。哦，天哪。我的脑子完全炸裂了。我觉得就像——你见过那个视频吗，有个家伙假装在变魔术，他拿了一根吸管，
I thought the dog was brown. Anyways. So let's say the quick brown fox. Any word probably works. So, you know, this algorithm will learn, you know, like you give it the quick brown and then it has to produce fox, right? Now, if you look at that in isolation, that's like almost impossible. But you give it a ton of these sentences. And, you know, in every sentence, you say, okay, here's the first word, predict the second one. Okay. Here's the first two words, predict the third one, predict the fourth
然后让他的朋友把吸管放在另一个家伙的背后面，这让他震惊得不得了。无论如何。是的。我现在就是那个状态。所以，哇，这太酷了。好吧。所以，是不是“the quick brown fox”（敏捷的棕色狐狸）或者不是，那个敏捷的——我以为那只狗是棕色的。那只棕色的狐狸跳过了懒狗。
one. Right. And you give it, you know, all of Wikipedia or something. Right. And so, you know, yeah, I mean, for some of these subjects and objects, it's going to be really difficult, like the quick brown, it could be anything, but you're going to also see a lot of correlation so you'll notice like whenever you see of like maybe you see the afterwards very common and so you'll actually learn a lot of structure from doing that from what they call a forward model right and the awesome thing is it's effectively free this is another thing because because of Moore's law and because computers have become so cheap and so efficient, you know, it's really the people time that's the killer for a lot of these things. Like if you can eliminate the time that a human has to do something,
我以为那只狗是棕色的。无论如何。所以我们假设是“the quick brown fox”。任何词大概都能用。所以，你知道，这个算法会学习，你知道，你给它“the quick brown”，然后它必须生成“fox”（狐狸），对吧？现在，如果你孤立地看这一点，那几乎是不可能的。但你给它提供大量的句子。而且，你知道，在每个句子中，你都说，好吧，这里是第一个词，预测第二个词。好吧。这里是前两个词，预测第三个词，预测第四个
you're in really good shape. And so, you know, with these forward models, you just download Wikipedia. I mean, you could do this on your laptop right now and predict the next word. You don't have to pay any humans to rate any sentences or anything. So now you have this embedding, which says, given a part of a sentence, I have some point in some space based on what word's coming next. And so, you know, sentence fragments where the next word is going to be fox will all kind of be close together, right? It turns out now if you do that same translation problem, but you work with that embedded space instead of with whole sentences, you need, and it's been a while since I saw this, but I think it's like one one-thousandth of the data or something like that. I mean, it's extraordinary. I mean,
词。对吧。你把它喂给它，比如维基百科的全部内容或者别的什么。对吧。所以，你知道，是的，我的意思是，对于其中一些主语和宾语来说，这会非常困难，比如“the quick brown”，后面可以接任何东西，但你也会看到大量的相关性，所以你会注意到，每当你看的时候——也许你会看到“of”或者“the”在后面非常常见，所以你实际上会通过这种方式从他们所谓的正向模型（Forward Model）中学习到大量的结构，对吧？而最棒的是，它实际上是免费的。这也是另一件事，因为摩尔定律，以及因为电脑变得如此便宜且高效，你知道，对许多这类事情来说，真正让人头疼的是人类的时间。如果你能消除人类必须做某事的时间，
the difference is unbelievable. And so, you know, what used to take millions and millions of sentences, you know, now after like 10,000 sentences, you're done. And there's even models now where they've embedded, they've actually done this jointly with different languages. And so they embed like literally every language into the same space. And then all they have to do is train the second half of it, which does the translation part. Yeah, so all of natural language processing completely redone with self-supervised learning. Like it's massively changed that field. And I think even with image processing, you're starting to see a lot of interesting things. The image equivalent of this is where you basically cut a piece of an image out and you say, reconstruct that missing piece of the image. It's like, remember the magic eraser that adobe photoshop thing that was like really popular like 10 years ago content aware yeah yeah yeah so you could and so uh you could actually yeah you could erase a person and it'll fill the
你的处境就会非常好。所以，通过这些正向模型，你只需下载维基百科。我的意思是，你现在就可以在你的笔记本电脑上完成这个并预测下一个词。你不需要花钱雇任何人类去给任何句子打分之类。所以现在你有了这个嵌入，它表示，给定句子的某一部分，根据接下来的词，我在某个空间中有一个点。所以，你知道，下一个词将是“fox”的句子片段都会在某种程度上靠得很近，对吧？事实证明，现在如果你做同样的翻译任务，但你使用的是那个嵌入空间而不是整个句子，你所需要的数据——距离我上次看到这个已经有一段时间了——但我认为大约是全部数据的千分之一左右，或者诸如此类。我的意思是，这太非同寻常了。我的意思是，
behind them right so imagine you know you you cut the person out, but your intent in this case isn't to literally cut them out of the picture. It's to see how good your reconstruction can be. And you immediately know what the algorithm did right and didn't do right. So in this case, you actually wanted to generate. So you wouldn't do something really difficult like cut out an entire person. You'd randomly cut out squares. And some of the time it would be impossible because you cut out an entire person you would you'd randomly cut out squares and some of the time it would be impossible because you cut out a whole car or something but most of the time you'll cut off parts of things and you'll be able to like if you cut out one person's eye you just copy their other eye or whatever yeah or something yeah exactly
其中的差异令人难以置信。所以，你知道，以前需要数百万个句子的任务，现在在大概1,000个句子之后就完成了。现在甚至还有这样的模型，它们将不同的语言联合起来进行了嵌入。所以它们实际上把字面意义上的每一种语言都嵌入到同一个空间中。然后它们所需要做的就是训练它的后半部分，也就是负责翻译的部分。是的，所以所有的自然语言处理都完全用自监督学习重做了一遍。它彻底改变了那个领域。而且我认为即使在图像处理中，你也能开始看到很多有趣的东西。这其中的图像对应物是，你基本上切掉图像的一部分，然后说：重建图像中缺失的那部分。就像——还记得大约10年前非常流行的Adobe Photoshop里的那个神奇橡皮擦工具吗？基于内容识别的——对，对，对。所以你可以——并且所以你可以——实际上你可以擦除一个人，然后它会把他们背后的东西填充起来，对吧？所以想象一下，你知道，你把一个人切掉了，但你在这个时候的目的并不是字面意思上把他们从照片里切掉。而是看看你的重建效果能有多好。而且你立刻就能知道算法做对了什么、做错了什么。所以在这种情况下，你实际上是想要生成。所以你不会做像切掉整个人这样非常困难的事情。你会随机切掉正方形。有些时候这会是不可能的，因为你切掉了一个整个人——你会随机切掉正方形，有些时候这会是不可能的，因为你切掉了一整辆汽车或类似的东西，但大多数时候你会切掉事物的某些部分，并且你将能够——如果你切掉了一个人的眼睛，你只需复制他们的另一只眼睛或者诸如此类。是的，或者类似的东西。是的，完全正确。
and so same kind of thing so you you have this model that reconstructs things by putting them into this big described. And then they trained another model on images. And then they created another thing which said, I have captions for images. So I have like a picture of the quick brown fox jumping over the lazy dog. And then I have that caption. Those two points should be close together. And then I'm going to take captions that don't belong with their picture, mismatched caption picture pairs, and those points should be far
所以情况大同小异。所以你拥有了这个模型，它通过将事物放入这个庞大描述的空间中来重建它们。然后他们在图像上训练了另一个模型。接着他们创建了另一个东西，它说：我有图像的标题。所以比如我有一张“敏捷的棕色狐狸跳过懒狗”的照片。然后我有那个标题。这两个点应该靠得很近。然后我要获取那些与它们的图片不匹配的标题，也就是错配的标题-图片对，这些点应该相距
apart. And I'm going to take those input embeddings and now train, you know, another what's called a joint embedding that tries to unify or push apart those pairs. And that's how DALI works. So then, you know, when you go to OpenAI and you say, you know, astronaut eating ice cream on the moon, it's taking those three models, the language model, I guess it doesn't need the image model anymore, but it's taking the language model and, oh no, it does. It needs the language model, the image model model and this joint model it's using all three of them to generate that picture of that astronaut on the moon uh and the question is is the artemis capsule floating around the the moon in the background
甚远。然后我要获取这些输入嵌入，并去训练另一个所谓的联合嵌入（Joint Embedding），它试图统一或推开这些对子。这就是DALI（DALL-E）的工作原理。所以接着，你知道，当你去OpenAI对它说：一个宇航员在月球上吃冰淇淋，它就会采用这三个模型——语言模型，我想它不再需要图像模型了，但它采用语言模型和——哦不，它需要。它需要语言模型、图像模型以及这个联合模型，它同时使用这三个模型来生成那个宇航员在月球上的照片。问题是，阿耳忒弥斯（Artemis）飞船有没有作为背景漂浮在月球周围？
to tie this we should just type artemis into dolly and see if it's on the moon or not uh i think like but they have exclusions for like a lot of proper names and nouns and stuff so i don't know i don't know how that works ah really yeah i uh i used it a little bit i found it to be you know really captivating there's something powerful about that um i've always been a really big fan of dolly but uh other than this visual interactive fiction i haven't found a practical use for it well it feels good to do a do a duo episode i know it's been a while but uh going through the uh the habit of uh the first first uh few well many many episodes of you and i doing this together. It feels good to do it again,
为了验证这一点，我们应该直接在DALL-E里输入“artemis”，看看它是不是在月球上，或者别的什么。我感觉——不过它们对很多专有名词和名词等有限制，所以我不知道，我不知道那是怎么运作的。啊，真的吗？我——我用过一点，我发现它（你知道）真的很迷人。这里面有某种强大的力量。我一直都是DALL-E的超级粉丝，但——除了这种视觉交互式小说之外，我还没发现它的实际用途。嗯，能做一期双人主持的节目感觉真好。我知道这已经过去一段时间了，但——回顾——你和我一起做这个节目的最初几期——其实是很多很多期——的习惯。再次这样做感觉真好，
do our tools of the show, book of the show, news, and then this discussion about machine learning was a really good time. Yeah, definitely. I think these are all very accessible, approachable things. You can use SageMaker or other tools. You can train on all of Wikipedia without having to download it to your desktop if you don't want to. I think I saw, you know, training that model I just talked about run you like, like 30 bucks or something, which, you know, is the price of like going to the movies. So it's not it's not nothing. But it's also like, pretty amazing that for 30 bucks, you could train a model on, you know, the entire Wikipedia corpus, and it'll come out correct and everything. So, you know, it's a lot of fun, amazing times we're
做我们的节目工具、本期图书、新闻，然后是关于机器学习的这场讨论，这是一段非常美好的时光。是的，绝对的。我认为这些都是非常平易近人、容易理解的事情。你可以使用SageMaker或其他工具。你可以在整个维基百科上进行训练，如果你不想的话，甚至不需要把它下载到你的桌面。我好像看到，你知道，训练我刚才谈到的那个模型大概花你30美元左右，这（你知道）也就是去看一场电影的价格。所以这并非——并非微不足道。但与此同时，这也是一件非常了不起的事情，花30美元你就可以在一个包含了整个维基百科语料库的模型上进行训练，而且它出来的结果完全是正确的，等等。所以，你知道，这真的很有趣，我们正生活在
living in. And I guess as a like final thing, anything you build, you're going to need to collect some type of metric to understand the people who are using your product and and so this is a really good area for folks to brush up on all right and with that note um yeah it's really awesome doing a dual episode um looking forward to seeing this one come out looking forward to seeing if we're right or not about about our prediction and really looking forward to your emails we've been getting a ton of really great emails. So appreciate everybody out there. We do read them, even if Patrick has them marked as unread.
一个了不起的时代。我想作为最后一点，无论你构建什么，你都需要收集某种指标来了解正在使用你的产品的人们，所以这对大家来说是一个温习这些知识的好领域。好了，就说这些。是的，做一期双人主持的节目真的太棒了，很期待这一期的发布，很期待看看我们关于预测的看法究竟对不对，也非常期待你们的邮件。我们一直收到大量非常棒的邮件。所以非常感谢大家。我们确实会阅读它们，即使帕特里克把它们标为了未读。
He has looked at the subject. I actually, I think both of us literally read every email that we get on Programming Throwdown. So we really appreciate your support and supporting us on Patreon and Audible. So thanks so much. Definitely subscribe if you're not subscribed to the show using whatever podcast catcher. We should be on all of them at this point. If we're not, let us know. And we will catch you all in two weeks. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons
他看过了主题。其实，我认为我们俩字面意义上阅读了我们在《Programming Throwdown》收到的每一封邮件。所以我们真的很感激你们的支持，以及在Patreon和Audible上对我们的支持。非常感谢。如果你还没用任何播客客户端订阅本节目，请务必订阅。目前我们应该在所有平台上都有。如果没有，请告诉我们。我们两周后见。Eric Barnhart制作的音乐。《Programming Throwdown》遵循知识共享
attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，进行混音、改编，但你必须对我和帕特里克进行署名，并采用相同的授权方式分享。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。